[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title
tous les plus grands tournois d'échec il
se déroulent en présentiel ou en ligne
vivez comprenez en direct les parties
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
bases retrouvez toutes les infos
essentielles comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les comptes rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition aux
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chains.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs émoticônes et les
emojis disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
vous voulez streamer des échecs comme
vos créateurs préférés tels que vis
stream Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
Chess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors notre
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/ettings/ connectique
comme catégorie sur twitch et commencer
à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamer en direct votre
profits.com affichera votre stream
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties offert utiliser la
commande community streamer dans le chat
et faites grossir votre audience sans
plus attendre
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur ce
stream alors aujourd'hui grosse finale
entre Ali resa firs et Magnus Carsen
donc on avait déjà eu ce match il y a 2
jours et aujourd'hui et ben écoutez
c'est la revanche et à dire que ça va
tout tenter pour essayer de nous amener
comme le dit si bien dans le chat Neo
nous emmener jusqu'au bout de la nuit
alors on va vous remplir un petit peu le
fonctionnement de de ce tournoi et de
l'événement alors rapidement le bracket
et ben il est ici donc là vous avez
quinzaine qui a gagné tous ces matchs
vous avez vu deux et demi-heure et demi
contre tabat abeille deux et demi 1 et
demi contre carwana 3-0 contre Ali Raisa
là il le rejoue du coup en grande finale
et de son côté Ali reset 3-0 entre amis
sur torov un prix il a gagné deux et
demi 1 et demi contre so Wesley
pour perdre derrière trois zéros contre
karzen en finale des Winners donc en
perdant cette partie enfin ce match et
ben il est arrivé quand même en finale
des loosers et là il a battu la zavik 1
et demi à zéro et demi ça c'était hier
soir et du coup ça qualifie Rosa en
finale donc grande finale aujourd'hui
pour remporter le tournoi Ali réserva
devoir gagner deux matchs consécutifs
quand j'ai deux matchs vous savez que
c'est des matchs en 4 parties donc il
peut y avoir quatre parties ou trois ça
dépend vraiment du score du score du
match voyez par exemple 45 kirosa ça
fait 3-0 parce que la quatrième partie
sert à rien bien évidemment donc
Annie réserve va devoir gagner les deux
matchs alors qu'est-ce qui se passe si
45 gagne le premier match et ben le
tournoi est terminé car ça ne pourra
gagner l'événement et à livrer sera
deuxième par contre si elle est réserve
pas Magnus dans le premier match
et ben les deux ont perdu un match donc
il y aura un dernier match de départage
avec vous savez à chaque fois donc dans
chaque match si on arrive à égalité avec
deux deux et ben il y aura un
département
donc le magasin c'est vraiment un des
partages
avec enchères qui est assez sympa donc
chaque joueur mise sur le temps qu'il
veut bien jouer avec les noirs et le
genre qui aura misé le plus bas choisis
sa couleur donc en fait on pensait
depuis longtemps que le joueur qui parie
le plus bas avait en fait les Noirs mais
on a vu le rampe Freyssinet il y a deux
jours sur le stream et apparemment il a
joué un mal dedans et en gagnant
l'Armageddon et ben ils ont dû choisir
la couleur qu'il voulait donc ça c'était
encore autre chose alors je vous
remettre un petit peu la caméra donc les
gens sont pas encore arrivés c'est pour
ça que je vous ai pas mis encore les
caméras des joueurs je regarde tout à
l'heure donc normalement
ah si je vois qu'ils viennent d'arriver
je vais essayer de les ping
normalement ça commence à 15 donc il
devrait déjà être là je vais regarder de
mon côté si les caméras sont bien mises
et je vois que Ali resa est là quantième
il est pas encore là mais comme vous la
mettre en a comme ça vous voyez on a la
caméra chez Ali resa et Magnus il est
pas encore devant la caméra mais mais
normalement il est il est là donc en
tout cas bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le
stream j'espère que vous allez tous très
bien et que vous passez un excellent
dimanche alors je veux voir un petit peu
le chat j'ai rien lu depuis que je suis
arrivé je suis désolé donc bonjour à
tous En tout cas j'ai pas tous vous
nommer mais bonjour à tous En tout cas
est-ce que il y a des questions que je
vais préparer au bout de la nuit ces
dernières actes ouais alors c'est clair
que si il y a des raisins le premier set
il y aura un deuxième set donc ça peut
durer très très longtemps cette histoire
donc voilà bonsoir à tous salut power
salut Kyriad salut à tous
j'ai fort réussir à trouver le McDo une
fois dans le premier set
ok après après
aller-retza il a il a déjà battu Magnus
plein de fois il a même gagné vous
souvenez je champion du monde de Bullet
à l'époque et il y a plein plein de de
enfin il a eu plein de temps en faveur
donc bien sûr ma news favoris mais après
sur ce match tout peut arriver je pense
que déjà Magnus dans les ouvertures il a
été meilleur l'autre jour que Camille
raisin donc là il va falloir qu'il reste
élite les débat théoriques et voir un
petit peu ce qui se passe mais écoutez
moi je pense que les raisins et là c'est
chance c'est dans un bon mood
franchement il a sa chance
d'avoir un petit peu c'est vrai que
malgré lui dans ce tournoi il est
vraiment vraiment au dessus il est
vraiment très très en forme donc on va
voir un petit peu
s'il y a des raisins peut le rattraper
et peut
surpasser Magnus dans ces deux cette
forme dans le premier test déjà et après
avoir tout le monde deuxième
pareil du formatoma et ben écoute c'est
tournoi là de base c'est pas un tournoi
d'échec c'est un tournoi qui a été qui a
été créé par plein de plein de je crois
que c'est comment s'appelle ça c'est il
y a des
[Musique]
une série de jeux online gaming qui aura
adopté ce format là et du coup aux
échecs on l'a aussi adopté et je trouve
que c'est vraiment intéressant pour le
coup parce que tu peux faire une fois
mais après tu peux revenir toi
et
hola gileté comme elle
et alors oui j'ai des amis espagnols
dans le chat donc c'est pas un espagnol
ça m'a mis argentin c'est chez qui
j'allais streamer quand j'étais en
Argentine parce qu'il avait un super
ordinateur
et en Argentine et ben j'avais un peu du
mal des fois que la connexion avec mon
ordi etc donc quand je devais stream un
événement que c'est comme j'allais chez
lui et donc il vient nous voir sur le
chat
exactement faire naître Nicolas c'est ça
consciencieux
alors le tournoi qui devrait commencer
je pense dans quelques minutes
maintenant ça commence à 15 il est 13
j'ai pas encore la partie créée sur
James com ça devrait pas tarder
ça devrait arriver très bientôt en tout
cas j'espère que vous êtes chaud les
gars pour encourager algéreza dans ce
match
il va en avoir bien besoin
et salut à térac aussi sur Youtube alors
j'en profite d'ailleurs de parler de
YouTube pour vous rappeler vous savez
les stats les stats qu'on a avec Youtube
c'est qu'en fait 30 % seulement des gens
qui nous regardent via YouTube et Ben
sont abonnés à la chaîne donc ça par
contre c'est inacceptable les gens vous
regardez vous vous abonnez en vrai c'est
c'est gratuit ça coûte rien et puis vous
en plus au courant de tout ce qui va se
passer sur Youtube que ce soit des
vidéos des shorts que ce soit des lives
donc franchement abonnez-vous sans
attendre c'est interdit ça salut cheese
fish et pareil si vous en gardez aussi
sur sur twitch sachez que on ne mord pas
et vous pouvez aussi vous follow enfin
nous follow donc gratuitement pour être
au courant dès qu'on est live donc
franchement c'est cool abonnez-vous
enfin
suivez-nous de base
toutes les chaînes je sais bien Mr wesh
mais du coup bah là si vous êtes là et
ben je regarde Alban Riom qui sans viser
et ben Alban t'as plus qu'à appuyer sur
un petit bouton pas très compliqué tu
peux le faire je pense et voilà et j'en
profite aussi pour parler de ma chaîne
vous savez que moi si je stream sur ma
propre chaîne et donc ma chaîne twitch
c'est stouf que je pense que vous
connaissez la majorité sur cette chaîne
ici donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas à me
follow si jamais vous aimez ce qu'on
fait ici et
bien sûr j'ai aussi une chaîne YouTube
sur laquelle je vais enfin je je mets
quotidiennement
des vidéos des shorts plein de choses
d'ailleurs j'ai enfin tourné la vidéo
dans laquelle je suis enfin passé mettre
international vous savez que c'était il
y a très très peu de temps il y a
quelques semaines j'ai tourné la vidéo
aujourd'hui
et la vidéo va sortir demain après-midi
donc soyez prêts pour voir la vidéo donc
pour ceux qui veulent la voir je vous
invite à venir vite sur ma chaîne
youtube donc c'est tout échec vous
pouvez me trouver je pense
c'est pas très compliqué aussi et si
vous me trouvez aussi appuyer sur la
petite cloche pour pour vous pour nous
follow
Amy way c'est quelques semaines
quelques semaines alors je sais trouver
le match Carlson
Ali resa mais ce n'est pas encore lancé
chez moi en tout cas
j'attends les parties donc ça va
commencer encore ça va commencer par là
la partie que vous avez devant devant
nous c'est pas du tout la partie du
tournoi c'est la partie d'hier les
résultats contre contre laservic à Rome
1 du match qu'ils ont joué hier mais
c'est pour que vous ayez un échiquier
sinon il y a plus rien et c'est juste
moche mais c'est pas la partie du tout
du tournoi et ça va commencer dans
quelques instants je réfère pas à chaque
fois en espérant que ça arrive mais ça
n'arrive pas encore
c'est humide chez Magnus malheureusement
j'ai pas le R6 chez Ali Reda je crois
qu'il l'a pas son petit appareil
je crois qu'il l'a pas l'appareil
toujours en train d'essayer de
de voir
ça devrait commencer
alors il y a toujours pas de partie
ça se voit un peu les joueurs ils ont on
le sait on le voit qu'ils ont pas
commencé le match
il y a pas d'air déjà peut-être que on
va le voir
ouvrir la fenêtre
avant la fin du match
non il est parti afficher mais voilà
c'est soyez à ça soit je l'enlève et
vous voyez vous voyez ça regardez
c'est juste moche donc du coup j'en ai
mis une au hasard mais c'est juste pour
vous expliquer un truc devant les yeux
mais c'est pas du tout la partie du
tournoi donc patience ça va arriver et
ça y est je vois la partie qui fasse
s'afficher
d'ici
quelques secondes je pense maintenant et
genre d'avoir commencé en tout cas vous
savez qu'on a une minute de retard par
rapport aux caméras
par rapport aux caméras on a une minute
de retard donc s'ils ont commencé et ben
nous on va l'avoir bientôt et la partie
je l'ai ça y est
alors les temps faisait pas encore ça va
arriver aussi dès que ça commence les
temps vont apparaître
et la partie va commencer par une prédit
on peut en faire une d'ailleurs hier je
sais pas si vous si vous avez vu mais je
vous ai rendu des points pour ceux qui
pour ceux qui
avaient parié sur la sur le match de Ali
resa alors je vous fais une prédit
alors
la faire
prédit qui va durer 2 minutes
ok allez les gars vous pouvez voter les
points de chaîne vous avez deux minutes
pour voter sur le score de votre choix
hier il y a eu la razzia quand on a eu
allez résa qui a battu qui a battu
lasavik sur le sur le gong il était pas
favori du tout
allez on voit que Magnus là il y a tout
le monde qui parie sur Magnus
alors le pari déjà il faut être clair
sur Paris il est pourquoi pour le
premier set ou pour le total déjà soyons
clairs je crois qu'on va décider avant
avant toute chose moi je propose que le
pari qu'on a fait c'est sur le premier
set parce que sinon ça fera des
histoires et la côte elle est pas très
grande du coup donc ce pari là il est
sur le premier set et s'il y a le
premier set on refait encore un une
prédit je pense ça va le faire c'est
cool la prédiction elle est sur elle est
sur twitch Alban ouais
c'est à dire que Alban il voit pas la
prédit alors qu'à Alban il vient de
s'abonner sur Youtube ça veut dire Alban
maintenant il faut que tu viennes
t'abonner sur twitch
et tu verras la crédit voilà on va
réussir à faire abonner à la banque
partout quoi c'est l'objectif de la
journée alors donc une Espagnole
tranquille assez standard tout ça donc
il y a quand même à fond alors
généralement dans ces positions le fruit
il y a quand même plutôt en C5 c'est
plus standard de mettre le fou en C5
mais ok donc le plan je me dis que c'est
fou et fuite ici alors fouet fluide ça a
plusieurs idées
il va faire plus tard c'est sûr
ça permet de défendre le pion au sens
avec la tour pour ensuite éventuellement
préparer un coup comme D5 et après une
prise avoir la tour qui va défendre le
pion en E5 mais fou fu ça peut aussi
préparer la future fiancetto des Noirs
je pense ça va être un des plans d'aller
dans la position qu'on peut imaginer à 4
c'est un coup qu'on peut souvent voir on
a aussi cavaler des deux avec cavalier
F1 cavalier hyper hyper standard dans
toutes ses positions et quand Caval
arrive en G3 généralement on joue G6
pour empêcher de cavalier et du coup
comme le foot en réfute et ben du coup
je la casse pour le fou en G7 vous voyez
ça c'est assez standard comme comme coup
comme pose je sais pas du tout si ça va
être possible la position elle est un
peu bizarre par rapport à d'habitude
vous savez que le Fou est souvent en C5
les mêmes positions avec le four en C5
les scors c'est 0 0.0 tu le vois ça les
routes comment vas-tu
alors donc faut baisser
pourquoi il y a deux choses A4 c'est un
coup qui qui est joué par beaucoup
beaucoup de monde dans ces positions et
ben moi je vous dire une chose je vous
déconseille de le faire tout le temps
dans cette position s'il y a des moments
où c'est bien et des moments où c'est
pas bien et si on fait tout le temps et
ben il y a une chance sur le morceau
alors pourquoi ça peut être pas bon ce
petit coup à 4 parce que plein de fois
et bien vous affaiblissez la case B3 qui
peut un jour être utilisé à votre
rencontre par exemple le jour où je suis
cavaler à 5 c'est 5 plein de fois que le
fond aussi je peux vraiment contrôler la
case B3 et il peut avoir un souci dans
plein de pollution bon ça va je sais pas
du tout si on a un je pense que c'est un
coup qui m'anère relativement ok pour
les blancs permet de pouvoir échanger et
ouvrir la colonne A mais attention que
A4 c'est pas toujours le coup qu'on fait
à 100% dans ces positions
donc faut 3 avec les jouets ok donc ça
paraît logique parce que vous voyez dans
la position normale le fond noir est en
C5
et comme elle fout il dépense 5 et ben
je me dis que fou ou trois tu as pas du
coup le fond c'est 5 donc c'est plutôt
une bonne idée de la part de la part des
blancs de mettre le fou ici maintenant
attention il y a un coût qu'on peut
regarder c'est D4 on se dit mais
attention mais ne faut il va où en fait
mais après des quatre je peux toujours
manger je pense manger manger et faire
faux F4 qui est une possibilité ou alors
directement faire fouger ça
mais avoir
après il y a qu'à manger stratégique
après ce coup d'écart parce que si
jamais je bouge je m'en fous par exemple
les Noirs ici pourrait manger là mange
là et ici jouer un super coup qui serait
le coup ici B4 qui permettrait un jour
de pouvoir gagner le contrôle de la case
D4 dans le futur et avoir ce pion
arrière donc là on voit très bien que la
jauge n'aime pas du tout ce que je dis
mais voilà de manière générale
stratégiquement c'est que qui est
intéressant qui peut arriver souvent
donc là il y a eu H6
avant de faire des quatre
mais attention le fou qui a un petit peu
qui peut être un petit peu des fois
mal placé avec des cartes qui peut
arriver mais bon j'ai cavalé F1 qui
avait extra qu'un petit donne des cases
à ce fou donc avoir un petit peu ce qui
va se passer
et mamie c'est l'art distrait il y a un
truc qui est à côté qui l'embête j'ai
l'impression il a son regard qui tourne
tout le temps sur sa gauche je sais pas
si il y a un truc qui le dérange je
crois que c'est l'air qui est qui est
faire pas assez pas assez d'air
peut-être il se demande s'il est pas
ouvert la fenêtre je sais pas ce qui
c'est pas à quoi il pense
et salut ciel bleu
à quatre foulées
là avec le fou G5 le Haka des trucs qui
n'ont pas été joué le fou noir qui va
souvent d'ailleurs en C5 qui a été mis
en E7 dès le début de partie c'est c'est
une position intéressante alors Caval et
B3 alors c'est vrai que maintenant qu'il
y a eu B5
Magnus a envie peut-être d'aller
chercher
la casse C5 pour ces pièces donc c'est
un coup intéressant qui pose des
questions alors que maintenant T4 ça a
l'air d'être un coup qui est interdit
parce que je vais tout simplement manger
l'option gratos
cavalier B3 ça empêche d'écart et ça met
éventuellement
une pièce en C5 donc comment est-ce
qu'on va continuer ici avec
avec les noirs
[Musique]
pas évident
parce que la tension du centre ici moi
me fait un peu peur j'aime pas laisser
un centre trop longtemps comme ça
cette prise là mais bon la prise ici je
pense qu'elle va simplement donner en
tâche blanc
plus tard ça a pas d'être génial pour
les Noirs ici
comment est-ce qu'on répond sur cavaler
B3
salut bisous
salut
plein standards ouais
dame décide dangereuse
c'est bizarre de me dire directement sur
sur le foot donc je vois pas trop
l'intérêt route
pour 14h salut à tous dames oui alors il
y a eu à 5 pour essayer ce cavalier et
donc A4 pour empêcher tout ça et
maintenant il y a eu B4 de la part
de la part des noirs
et encore un combat de case un combat de
case important vous voyez si je bouge un
pion je perds tout le contrôle des cases
et là ce qu'on me lasserait pas
avec les Noirs comme tout à l'heure une
idée
pour essayer un genre de gagner des
cases alors j'ai aussi fou à 6 qui par
un jour être une idée taper sur le puis
on des trois
je pensais à un coup mais ça va pas être
génial j'essaye d'essayer de créer un
truc au centre pour gagner des cases du
style prise et des quatre gagner la
casse des quatre un jour mais ça risque
de perdre un pion quand même cette
histoire
et j'étais pas assez de jeu ici
alors qu'est-ce que mes filles on n'a
pas de discorde malheureusement Karine
Dutron 35 mais si tu recherches un
discord j'en ai un moi j'en ai un perso
avec ma chaîne échec tu peux trouver sur
tout peut-être mais sur la chaîne de
James come fr il y a pas de discorde
qu'avez eu pour recycler en 17 ça va
être possible mais là il y a une grosse
tension au centre faire attention ne pas
être trop
passif quand même
voilà c'est au blanc de jouer hein
savoir ce que les blancs vont jouer
donc on peut imaginer le sac comme
tourbé plus tard il faut assise pour
taper sur la colonne B et sur l'option
V3 donc anticiper peut-être un truc
comme ça mais trop bien mal un peu
bizarre quand même on met pas une tour
derrière un pion comme ça
exactement
on va toujours dans ce sens là
bah c'est moi qui fait l'animation ici
en ce moment donc si vous êtes là aussi
j'en profite
donc qu'est-ce qui va jouer
ma partie enfin il y a pas très mal au
temps non plus mais quand même 3 minutes
de retard
c'est quand même quelque chose attention
que si il n'obtiens pas davantage ça
peut être un moyen de pression pour pour
aller raisin cette partie
ça peut être un moyen de pression claire
pour les noirs
et j'ai mon chat en train de défoncer ma
chaise derrière je crois que je vais le
faire sortir
alors B4
je sais pas comment on peut jouer avec
les blanches je trouve pas l'idée
j'ai pas aimé ce foudre à moi je suis
parti sur un plan un plan standard avec
comme ça j'aime bien
alors hop
j'ai perdu le chat OK
alors la finale c'est surtout la soirée
alors ça dépend en fait ta cadence c'est
15 + 3 vous savez et en fait par rapport
au tournoi et ben chaque joueur a droit
à deux vies donc première fois tu perds
tu peux rejouer et tu perds une deuxième
fois t'éliminer là c'est la grande
finale dans laquelle Carlson pour
l'instant a gagné tous ces matchs et à
l'ireza qui est en face a perdu un seul
match du tournoi contre Magnus
auparavant donc si Magnus gagne ce
premier match contre les raisins et ben
les raisins aura grillé ces deux vies
donc sera éliminé donc ma news gagnera
l'événement par contre si à l'ireza
gagne le match et ben les deux joueurs
auront grillé un une vie donc il y aura
un match supplémentaire pour voir qui va
être éliminé dans cette compétition donc
ça peut être
trois parties
ça peut être cinq parties enfin quatre
parties ou même cinq siamaganem mais
après si elle est Raisa gagne ça peut
aussi encore il y a un autre match
derrière qui peut encore durer longtemps
donc minimum trois parties maximum 10
parties puis avoir un magret donc un
match aller
Armageddon et real par exemple
donc trois parties minimum 5 parties
maximum donc aussi bien on est là pour
1h30 aussi bien on est là pour 6h à peu
près donc accrochez-vous en tout cas on
va espérer en moi j'espère qu'il y a des
réserves a gagné ce match donc du coup
j'espère qu'il y a un deuxième set je
pense que pour pour la hype pour toi
c'est quand même bien qui est un
deuxième match c'est cool
et donc on va voir un petit peu ce qui
se passe quoi
donc c'est un bo4 c'est ça
cette formule elle sort alors je sais
pas si quelqu'un dans le chat peut nous
éclairer un peu plus mais on m'a dit que
cette formule sortait de alors je sais
plus comment ça s'appelle exactement
mais c'est une formule qu'on utilise
beaucoup dans certains jeux online
et je pense que vous pouvez peut-être
plus nous
eSport
etc et je pense que c'est une formule
plutôt intéressante franchement
c'est une formule plutôt intéressante
jouer
de la part de
Magnus donc cavalier H2 il veut sûrement
cavalier
cavaler G4
allez je vais sortir mon chat c'est
l'heure de manger soit je le sors
maintenant et je vais être tranquille
soit il va défoncer la porte donc je
reviens dans une seconde
où la présente rapidement si vous voulez
la connaître voilà c'est Nala toute
mignonne et je repars avec
ok je suis de retour
va manger
alors mon cavalier a été joué par un
Magnus
je trouve vraiment très intéressant ce
système de de
d'appareillement enfin le tournoi parce
que franchement
tu peux toujours avoir un mauvais jour
mal joué et puis revenir après donc
c'est vrai que ça favorise quand même
pas mal les meilleures joueurs
parce que ben tu peux avoir une chance
et revenir derrière comme là les raisins
il y a pas de un match mais
il rejoue quoi vous voyez et donc il a
joué ce que j'avais dit prise et D4 et
maintenant il a la case B4 avec les
noirs et écoutez je trouve que que ce
qu'a fait à l'IRISA jusque là c'est
plutôt intéressant donc clairement il y
a une majorité on va dire de ce côté là
avec les Noirs les Noirs ils vont
essayer de jouer avec même peut-être fou
P4 est intéressant avec l'idée
d'échanger les fous de case noire pour
remettre un Cavalaire en B4 sans se
faire échanger ça c'est intéressant et
j'ai aussi plus tard C5 C4 qui peut
arriver avec les noirs et essayer plus
tard de balayer et de pousser les pions
au centre d'un autre côté maintenant que
le Pione des noirs a disparu et ben je
peux aussi avoir une majorité plutôt
centrale avoir el roi pour attaquer
frontalement le roi Nord voilà et avoir
aussi que depuis que j'ai le pion en
décape dans le fou c'est deux bah il est
pas terrible donc on peut imaginer avec
les Blancs brûle cavalier mettre le fou
sur sa belle case pour venir en
vis-à-vis avec le avec le bras noir vous
voyez toujours essayer dans les
positions d'améliorer les pièces et de
voir quelle pièce sont bonnes quelles
pièces sont pas bonnes pour réussir
vraiment à comprendre tout ça là ce four
est royal il a de deux belles diagonales
donc il est super bien surtout par
contre ce fou ben très très moche donc
je sais pas brûle cavalier peut-être
ancien faire fou B3 le cavalier le
sortir par là par là enfin je sais pas
trouver un truc mais là c'est un peu la
stratégie essayer de replacer des pièces
sur des bonnes cases pour réussir à bien
attaquer vous voyez regarde ce que fait
les raisins ok
sûrement vers ces cases là ici ou ici
pour venir sur une meilleure case donc
c'est vraiment un jeu de de préparation
de stratégie dans le genre sont en train
de de replacer leurs pièces
donc ok allez raisin qui a une bonne
position et en plus autant il y a une
pression clairement il y a quand même
d'avance et
intéressant en tout cas cette pause
c'est aller réserver la pression avec
les noirs pour cette première partie ça
s'appelle pas mal niveau psychologie
déjà parce que je vous rappelle que le
premier match qu'ils ont joué dans ce
tournoi et ben les raisins a perdu 3-0
et en plus c'était trois parties
difficiles dont une où il était gagnant
mais une partie complètement folle les
coups de ordi à trouver c'était
introuvable mais
c'est vrai que pour la confiance il
pouvait commencer
en rayonne partie ou vraiment
enrichissant à mettre la pression sur
Magnus ça pourrait vraiment être très
intéressant
alors ma revanche contre barbix
je sais pas encore
celle le match précédent et mais on se
refera ça avec grand plaisir
et d'ailleurs depuis que je suis devenu
ami et ben
barbix s'est mis en tête de
d'essayer de passer grand maître et qui
peut pas supporter d'avoir le même titre
que moi et je comprends bien je
comprends bien sa place je serai
exactement pareil quelle honte
donc on va voir un petit peu
on fera un petit ROG tout GM avec barbix
ça peut être marrant d'ailleurs
éventuellement sur la chaîne qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez un petit Raoul tout
GM
pour Barbie c'est pas pour moi je
sais pas pour l'instant
c'est pas pour l'instant ce que je vais
faire moi j'ai pas la prétention pour
l'instant de dire que c'est quelque
chose qui est très très difficile pour
l'instant j'en ai conscience
et
et voilà voilà on verra plus tard
éventuellement si j'arrive à monter mais
pas d'illusion c'est un niveau qui est
stratosphérique est bien au dessus de
pour l'instant de mes capacités donc
pour l'instant pour l'instant
je
voilà je ferais pas de retour GM mais
voilà par contre barbix lui il a 24 de
la 2400 combien 2400 à peu près il a une
norme de grand maître il en faut 3 il a
un bon élo peut-être que
faire une une catégorie rock tout GM
avec barbix ça pourrait être sympa
peut-être je lui ai proposé
faire des vidéos plus un peu commenter
c'est parti suivre un petit peu le petit
barbix en vrai ça pourrait être sympa ça
c'est un maître international qui est
souvent sur la chaîne et qui est très
sympathique et
donc et donc ça peut être sympa mais moi
tout GM non moi j'ai pas assez j'ai pas
assez de niveau
là actuellement je dois être en 2300 60
à peu près en feed je viens de perdre 40
points de mon dernier tournoi
je pars de 1400 hello exprès pour passer
maître et là je pense que trop contente
de passer maître trop content de passer
2400 j'ai fait un tournoi à Boom -45
mais on va se on va se remettre très
très vite vous inquiétez pas
je sais pas quand est-ce que je vais
rejouer parce qu'il y a pas trop de
tournois ici mais un jour on essaiera de
on essaiera de remonter un peu à 2400
donc Barbie c'est Pierre Barbot avec
ôté à la fin et c'est un maître
international qui est très fort c'est un
des un des amis un des plus forts maître
de France
donc c'est cool qui puisse passer
grand-mère en tout cas moi je vous
souhaite c'est cool c'est vraiment un
très bon ami donc
on lui souhaite même si je le considère
pas trop au niveau échec vous savez
qu'on se troll énormément entre nous et
que on aime bien se dire des vilaines
choses alors pour ces quatre dames des 6
intéressants donc Dame des 6 qui
défendent cavalier je pense qu'il va me
lasser faut assister
pas trop il y a le cavalier en prison
même barbix le verrez ça vous imaginez
bien donc Dame des 6 et on va mener à
cette fois assis c'est la tour elle a
pas trop de casse parce que vous voyez
qu'en fait c'est la tour elle va en ces
deux il y a du cavalier B4
et prendre le cavalier un peu des fêtes
parce que c'est le bon fou des blancs
donc le donner contre un pauvre cavalier
c'est c'est pas vraiment l'idéal écoutez
j'aime beaucoup mais j'aime énormément
la position d'aller regarder dans cette
partie je pense franchement
je pense franchement que
Cali Raisa peut faire quelque chose dans
ce match
s'il était FM finf il y a pas longtemps
et le je suis passé maître il y a il y a
à peu près un petit mois un petit mois
et tu déconnes
par rapport à eux
je pense qu'on a préparé parce que
Julien song il est maître international
on a le même loi actuellement à peu près
et je vois Kim il est maître field donc
il est un poil en dessous mais je crois
qu'il est pas mal remonté d'aller à un
moment donc je dirais assez équivalent
assez équivalent
après moi
contre Julien song j'avais perdu c'était
très très longtemps c'était en 2000 en
2012 je crois j'avais fait un tournoi
fermé un norme de MI et j'étais dans ma
période à la pire période de ma vie
j'avais perdu j'avais fait 14 mois en
parlant des points je me souviens
j'avais 14 mois pendant 14 minutes
pendant 14 mois chaque chaque mois je
parlais des points 14 mois
c'est ouf
des questions quand tu passes 14 mois et
qu'à chaque mois à chaque mois chaque
fois que tu joues tu perds des points
mais à chaque fois
et tu dis bon j'arrive plus à jouer
quand et j'ai perdu contre vu la sonde
dans ce tournoi là il avait été bien
meilleur que moi d'ailleurs il m'avait
éclaté
j'ai pas vu le jour
mais bon ça c'était il y a 11 ans
c'était il y a 11 ans
parce que
on sait jouer
[Musique]
la dernière fois qu'on sait jouer que
c'est assez marrant
IRL et j'ai perdu en moins de 10 coups
je crois
et majeur a une ouverture très bizarre
une prépa qu'il a l'habitude de
connaître et je connaissais pas du tout
et je me suis pris un vieux piège perdu
et bon c'est pas jeu beaucoup avec
Mathieu et avec Sébastien Mason c'est
juste une seule fois je crois c'est un
tournoi rapide aussi j'avais perdu mais
bon ça c'est encore des parties il y a
très très longtemps et Kevin bordi on
s'est vu sur internet mais on sait
jamais jouer en vrai donc
voilà voilà
dans ce tournage de marque intéressante
alors je te conseille clairement vos
teint d'aller voir le match malbus ayeza
les parties les trois parties qui sont à
jouer les trois sens sublimes les trois
déjà le match de la finale des gagnants
déjà il y a aussi une partie que j'ai
beaucoup aimé c'est la finale je crois
que c'est la ronde 2 du match Magnus
contre karwana il y a une finale qui a
le Magnus avec qui était du roi c'était
juste magnifique
après bon
tu peux l'avoir sur pièce comme tu vas
dans événement et tu allais parti tu as
un événement tu cherches le nom de
l'événement champions
tout ce que tu veux voilà ben écoutez
moi j'aime beaucoup la position de
le disais parce qu'en fait ici ce qui se
passe
c'est que
cette case en BK
et surtout comme ça peut-être que les
blancs vont être obligé de donner le Fou
et du coup ça serait perte de fou pour
les noirs et les pièces qui se marchent
un peu dessus ce x 2 qui est finalement
réussi à venir sur une bonne case mais
qui est quand même pas si bon que ça ici
donc j'aime beaucoup la position en tout
cas de
Dali raisin il faut agir ce que je
proposais c'est un mauvais coup à cause
de E5 alors que se passe qu'il a pris le
5 là il faut que je défende absolument
le cavalier donc le temps des 7 j'ai
l'impression on D5 mais venir en dessin
que c'est vraiment chercher les ennuis
après dame 17 c'est quoi les guides de
magnésie
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
parce que là il a pas de cases
C2 mais ces deux il y a cavalier B4 et
juste je suis pas bien en fait alors que
si je joue tu reprends ces 6
d'un prank avait les prendre des quatre
je vois que ça comme idée et ça a l'air
pas mal d'ailleurs parce que j'ai une
pression sur F7
et c'est la partie incroyable
alors moi c'est par déduction que j'ai
trouvé ton processus je suis pas du tout
alors niveau pour prendre un point C6
une qualité pour manger un pion pour
réussir à ouvrir un petit peu les deux
fous des blancs qui vont finir par être
très actifs c'est vraiment une très
bonne réaction de la part de Magnus
4 jours en France qui vivent uniquement
les tournois
oui alors c'est vrai que dans les échecs
il y a pas beaucoup pas beaucoup
d'argent c'est à vous le savez bien et
du coup pour vivre en tant que joueur et
ben c'est c'est très difficile donc oui
les quatre on peut les trouver on va
déjà on a déjà les raisins Maxime ça
c'est sûr après là je suis même pas sûr
derrière
on a Étienne Macron maisienne macro il
avait coaché aussi
Maxime maintenant c'est terminé leur
histoire mais
je pense quand même qu'Etienne il est
toujours quand même enfin il est encore
actif il a joué il a joué il a joué la
Coupe du Monde il a joué le tournoi et
en lui disant 3 je le Moussa je pense
que c'est aussi un joueur pro mais
[Musique]
c'est vrai que
voilà à part ces jours-là il y a quand
même pas beaucoup de monde qui est
capable de pouvoir vivre à des échecs à
même quand on est grand maître des
échecs en France même ailleurs c'est
difficile un simple grand maître à
2005-2006 malheureusement
[Musique]
ben c'est dur c'est dur tu es tout le
temps en tournoi tout en déplacement les
prix sont pas forcément évident à
prendre et c'est juste c'est hyper dur
quoi c'est hyper dur
très très dur
en gros il faut être il faut être ouais
top 100 mondial je pense pour bien vivre
des échecs
[Musique]
en tant que joueur
en fait il faut donner des cours il faut
faire autre chose donc moi j'ai pas de
twitch moi je dis moi je fais que des
échecs ça c'est c'est vrai mais je donne
des cours d'échec je suis entraîneur je
suis entraîneur professionnel c'est mon
métier donc je donne des cours je coach
et puis en plus je fais des commentaires
sur les réseaux et puis en plus je le
fais aussi du twitch je fais plein de
choses en fait tout ce qui est en
rapport avec les chèques et bien je fais
arbitre si vous voulez
en France j'avais le meilleur niveau
national d'arbitre et j'ai pas poursuivi
parce que je le faisais à la base pour
pour mon club
pour mon club mais maintenant que je
travaille plus dans le club en fait ça
m'intéresse pas de progresser en tant
qu'arbitre mais j'avais le meilleur
niveau d'arbitrage possible
alors cavalier français 6 donc là il y a
toujours cette qualité d'avance pour
pour les noirs et les blancs qui qui
cherche absolument du contre jeu est-ce
que tomber deux c'est un coup
trop bien ça peut forcer à comprendre
aussi ils sont un fou dessiner
un coup
prises
qui peuvent arriver vous voyez peut-être
ça il y a aussi ce qu'il faut se
regarder tout le temps avec ce diagonale
infernal qui peut s'ouvrir à tout moment
c'est assez compliqué mais en tout cas
les raisins qui a trois buts à la
pendule contre 28 secondes
et ça c'est un bel avantage niveau temps
parce que la pollution elle est
meilleure pour aller raisin mais aussi
en plus il est mieux autant ils peuvent
vraiment peut-être
terminer Magnus Magnus qui ajoute au
tempo qui a pas le temps de réfléchir et
quand même trois secondes par coup c'est
vrai mais
c'est mince quand même c'est mince comme
autant
donc elle va les prendre des cadres donc
ça en quatre parties ça c'est en quatre
parties
c'est en quatre parties ce match là
c'est la première celle là c'est la
première
il y a deux pions pour la qualité pour
les blancs donc la matériellement les
joueurs sont égaux un cavalier ça vaut
trois points et deux pions ça vaut un
point chacun ou 3 + 2 ça fait 5 et ça
roule une tour
peut-être que là je peux jouer des coups
comme comme peut-être
faire attention il y a plein de
fourchettes qui puissent enfin qui
peuvent arriver j'ai un peu peur
si j'arrive avec les Noirs
à mettre les pièces sur les bonnes cases
et bien je peux tout rafler par exemple
il faut qu'il y a ça en l'air il y a
plein de trucs qui peuvent se passer là
j'aime bien les Noirs mais
il faut vraiment aller jusqu'au bout
je pense que les raisins peuvent
vraiment gagner cette partie en tout cas
je te souhaite même pour la confiance
vous voyez pour la confiance c'est
vraiment quelque chose de
d'important qu'ils mettent un point en
cette partie
il est perdu en finale des gagnants il a
pas eu 3-0
et 3-0 avec trois belles défaites Manu
ça va être intraitable donc là pour le
moral si elle est résa arrive à gagner
la première partie ça peut vraiment
vraiment je pense faire basculer les
choses
qui pourrait être en prise plus tard
derrière donc il arrive changer il a
appris d'être probablement à 5 a été
joué
tour des deux hein paraît logique
attaque le fou
là peut-être mais j'ai l'impression que
l'impression que ça va si je fais ça
ou c'est trois tours là
elle va aller prendre aussi
c'est chaud c'est chaud alors on va
blender on voit l'ordinateur il donne
des points d'interrogation
ça va les gars tout se passe bien
c'est c'est hyper compliqué et puis même
hyper dur à comprendre le pourquoi du
comment mais en tout cas
en tout cas
ici à les réserves se débrouillent très
bien
[Musique]
il a une bonne position un avantage pour
prendre ces 7 quel est son idée
peut-être qu'il va lui s'essayer de
récupérer en A5 mais
c'est pas F3 avec les jouets
je pense qu'il va pêcher
de mettre son four en dessin que c'est
vrai que si réussir à mettre le fou ici
ça va pas être une bonne idée pour pour
les Noirs surtout qu'il serait très très
fort en catacré le pion G2 qui
défendrait le pion aussi
le lien également en pratique c'est
impossible regardez les joueurs ont 15
secondes chacun et la position aller
elle est hyper compliquée quoi donc
franchement
ça va quoi je vais vous mettre le time
un peu mieux
donc 10 secondes chacun là c'est la
loterie même si une quête de plus je
pense que c'est qu'un tête plus facile à
jouer pour
pour les blancs avec ce pion passé
mais en tout cas en tout cas on a vu
hier le match entre les et
là zavik on a vu la portion de Bullet et
franchement elle est Raisa il a été
tellement impressionnant qu'ici il faut
voir un peu s'il arrive à tenir donc là
une qualité de plus pour aller Raisa
mais trois pions quand même trois pions
pas mal de news donc c'est hyper tendu
hyper tendu
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr qu'ici il arrive à
organiser cette partie notre ami à
lireza s'il prend là je prends l'âge
qu'il y a plein de pions qui avancent je
sais pas trop quoi en penser
j'ai regardé mon fou par principe cette
tour là ouais et essayer de t'attaquer
le maximum de pions chacun surtout le
pion a que je vais manger parce qu'après
les quatre pions peut-être que je peux
plus les défendre que les autres
donne le pion ça peut pas le défendre
et maintenant il faut passer la tour
donc ça reste nul je pense tout ça
normalement ça risque de faire nul
toujours avantage avec ma tour ici mes
écoutes de pions je peux rien faire du
tout il va avancer des pions les pions
on s'échanger et ça va faire nul je
pense
tranquillement je vois pas du tout
malmuse perdre ça attention qui perd un
je crois quand même peut-être là
même celle-là peut-être 5
tours là
en tout cas elle je pense pas qu'il
puisse la perdre
mais attention
alors 6 secondes chacun prise
cavalier prend
ok surtout reprend H2
qu'est-ce qui se passe
OK
je vous rappelle qu'il y a un petit
délai il y a un délai de ouais d'une
minute avec avec la vidéo donc les
joueurs sont partis vous le savez bon ça
fait une blague
et les pions voilà échanger et nul
écoutez belle nul en tout cas
d'avoir des joueurs et à ça qui est
passé quand même pas loin de la victoire
dans ce match donc franchement c'est
quand même de bonne augure pour ce match
les deux bien joué d'être bien en forme
il avait les Noirs il a réussi à pousser
un petit peu et à mettre en danger
Magnus donc je pense que c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment de bonne augure pour le
match et j'espère que Ali resa va
réussir à l'emporter dans cette première
en tout cas dans ce premier set
donc je vais mettre le score à jour on
est à 0,5 chacun
chacun
est la partie la prochaine partie qui va
avoir lieu d'ici quelques minutes alors
vous savez que
vous savez que sur enfin pour cet
événement et ben c'est comme à plein de
partenaires donc des partenaires
de sponsors et donc on a pour obligation
de vous mettre la pub des sponsors pour
que vous puissiez un peu voir de quoi il
s'agit donc je profite des pubs pour à
chaque fois vous mettre des sponsors
donc je vais commencer par ça mais avant
ça je vais juste vous montrer le trophée
vous savez en fait que il serait bien
les événements de champions donc on a en
tout 6 tournois qualificatif pour une
grande finale qui aura eu du 9 au 16
décembre à Toronto donc là on est au
cinquième événement
et donc
les joueurs enfin les joueurs et
l'organisation a designé un beau trophée
pour cette grande finale qui jouera à
Toronto et il faut que je vous la montre
franchement ce trophée moi je trouve
vraiment très jolie regardez salut de ça
c'est un beau trophée et franchement
c'est un trophée un peu
différent de ce qu'on a vite d'avoir et
franchement il est sympa franchement tu
es assez dans ta collection je pense tu
es quand même pas mal et donc ça sera
vraiment pour
pour le gagnant de la grande finale donc
c'est un jeu vidéo bah je pense que ce
sont bien bien inspirés des espoirs etc
donc c'est ça il y a assez je confirme
d'accord avec toi mais en tout cas je
trouve que ça c'est sympa voilà voilà
donc petite pub pour vous montrer un
petit peu les partenaires de l'événement
et puis on se retrouve d'ici quelques
petites minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de retour alors que la partie va
commencer dans quelques instants donc à
l'ireza qui a les plans dans cette
partie
donc elle est résa qui a commencé avec
un une belle partie pour entamer ce
match donc je pense une partie qui avait
quand même plaisir un vu vu le premier
match de finale qu'ils ont joué ensemble
je vous rappelle il y a eu 3-0 pour
Magnus 3-0 très convaincant quand même
et je pense que commencer avec une
partie comme celle-là donc il a pas
gagné mais tu es quand même pas très
très loin il y a quand même fait
trembler Magnus qui mange sa carotte à
malus il est alors je sais pas ce qu'il
y a dans ces carottes mais franchement
depuis qu'il mange ses carottes Magnus
et ben il est il est hyper hyper costaud
quoi donc je tournoi il est extrêmement
impressionnant et
moi j'ai des carottes comme ça est-ce
que vous aimez comme ça moi je vomis en
direct je pense que si je mange ça je
vomis direct
c'est juste ce livre dégueulasse alors
le 4 c'est 5 6 6e c'est signe de 6 donc
on a eu cette partie alors là ça va être
hyper intéressant on a eu cette partie
lors du premier match et donc là il a
changé Magnus il a joué les quatre
cavaliers qu'avant il avait joué avec
Time man of avec Avensis puis à 6 donc
il a changé malheureusement j'aurais
bien aimé
voir l'épisode 2 sur Diamond of il y
avait une partie de fou furieux que vous
avez fait
c'est la grande ligne 7 F4 d'imbécile
ils sont je sais 4 full échec et roi E2
ou très très bizarre c'est le concours
c'est vrai et surtout B7 j'ai fait une
partie comme ça et je crois que le coup
sans vouloir répéter je crois que c'est
fou de je me trompe peut-être mais ma
partie très gouffe en Top 16 j'avais
joué le fou aux deux je crois j'avais
préparé ça avant et fou ou deux c'est 5
je crois que c'est petit rock que
j'avais joué
et
il y avait un cavalier 3 faut prendre
trois il faut prendre le 4 avec F4 il
faut F3 et c'est un bon avantage blanc
cette pollution c'est intéressant
il y a aussi Caval des 6 qui se jouent
il me semble d'ailleurs ici dans cette
pause je crois bien que cette position
qui avait des six
et je crois que c'est pas si clair mais
d'ailleurs je crois que l'ordinateur
mais je préférais la position sans
cavaliers de mvl comme ça etc je suis
pas sûr de Valentin je me souviens plus
mais je crois que c'était ça
c'est 5 rock que j'avais joué contre pas
mal très beau gosse
fouadou C4 ou alors C4 c'est oui
mais il me semble que fouettez plus
précis
je l'ai préparé ça j'avais préparé deux
lignes il y a un jeu fou deux à lire ça
c'est 5 et moi j'avais petit rock contre
et F4 et c'était c'était
une bonne
une bonne ligne que j'avais eu une bonne
position après j'ai perdu ma tante de
coup vous savez la spéciale stouf mais
j'avais une partie ah il joue comme moi
ah c'est ici alors qu'il faut jouer
comment c'était
à me souvenir je vais voir si en
référence j'ai des trucs
en référence c'est quoi là j'ai un doute
Adam c'est 7 donc là je dis n'importe
quoi avec cavaluation n'importe quoi
alors c'est ça ou pardon j'arrivais et
sur dame C7 c'est quoi le coup
je mélange ou quoi
au moins que ce soit non comment ça
marche là
je sais plus je sais plus comment ça va
alors fous d'essayer ce genre là on en a
parlé de ça avec faux F3
mais il me semble franchement que
j'avais pas vu ça moi j'avais je vois
quoi moi
je veux jouer F4
peut-être j'avais F4 plus
qu'est-ce qu'il me propose
meilleur coussin deuxième coussin
troisième coup F4 alors je sais plus ce
que j'avais joué j'avais lancé là mais
si ça me plaisait pas alors c'était
quand même le coup qui était chaud par
tous les meilleurs joueurs je voyais mvl
qui jouait tout le temps
cavalier 6 donc ça gagne la paire de fou
vous voyez et en plus les cases noires
donc c'est vraiment très intéressant
mais en pratique c'est ma valeur quand
même plus difficile parce que ce pion
souvent il est perdu et du coup je
voulais pas jouer ce genre de de
position contre Pavel qui était
carrément un excellent joueur C4
Cavalier rouge je pense qu'on peut
rendre la qualité en tout cas il y a un
fou qui va être perdu à son tour ici
bien sûr César sur Youtube je parlais
bien des carottes je parlais bien des
carottes parce que manger des carottes
crues comme ça juste moi je peux pas
bon déjà ceux qui me connaissent bien
savent que j'ai des petits problèmes à
manger des légumes mais comme ça de base
je fais des efforts en ce moment pour en
manger mais alors des carottes comme ça
vraiment
c'est le pire que je pourrais faire
c'est le pire que je pourrais faire dans
ma vie
et
quelle horreur donc faut F4 eux prend un
F4
par une saucisse vraiment carotte non
impossible
ok donc ce fou en E2 c'est un problème
quand même j'arrive pas à le sortir
alors peut-être fou des trois d’apprends
je suis pas sûr que j'ai une découverte
alors je peux le dire ok je peux jouer
ça a priori échec roi bouge
et peut-être fou F5 qui est un coup
j'essaie de calculer
X5 qui a l'air intéressant vous voyez
que si jamais on manque le temps comme
ça le pur il est perdu deux fois dessus
contre 0 donc ça a l'air intéressant
donc foudet 3 peut être une bonne idée
pour essayer de développer ce fou qui
est quand même derrière tout ces pions
et option enfin c'est au foot les
considéré comme être le mauvais fou de
la position donc peut-être que sur
foulard rock serait le coup peut-être
pour éviter de se faire déroquer après
rock il faut regarde un truc comme ça
d'imbécile si on dit que cette position
elle est ok
mais en tout cas je pense que fou
Detroit a l'air d'être un coup
important
donc avoir c'est le coup qui a été joué
par les raisins tout comme moi et
franchement c'est c'est pas c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle pour pour le français
et si joue comme moi il va vite
l'organisation
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là je pense que
petit
F5 c'est chaud et si d'en prendre il y a
ça je pense que tu dors ok obligatoire
donc 4 on mange les fous j'ai un pion
des 6
qui peut à la fois être fort et faible
on va imaginer ma position
B3 pour défendre ce pion donc ce pion
qui peut devenir une diablesse un jour
mais j'ai aussi depuis un F4 qui peuvent
aussi dire des faiblesses donc
avoir à voir
mais
en tout cas moi un coup assez important
est-ce que je peux aussi peut-être des
formes le pion de notre manière en tête
full art
je sais pas pas meilleur que le sien
c'est que son B3 enfin sur F3 peut-être
que il est pas génial peut-être je peux
garder les fous mais bon je sais pas ça
m'a l'air en tout cas compliqué
moi j'aime bien les positions ouvertes
avec de l'espace donc c'est clair je
préfère les blancs mais après
à quel point les blancs sont mieux c'est
pas si clair donc d'un premier six Babou
on a vu qu'il y avait tout un échec et
il faut F5 qui a récupéré le pion quoi
qu'il arrive tu bouges la dame je mange
au moins des 7 comme ça et tu prends ici
je prends là et ce pion il a défendable
parce que je suis comme deux fois dessus
donc je devrais dessus puis en plus tu
as les pièces qui sont quand même très
mal placées donc là c'est clairement
d'en prendre 6 ce sera pas un coup jouer
par Magnus en tout cas ce serait une
bonne nouvelle pour aller raisin qui
fasse d'apprendre les 6 mais ouh ça a
été joué incroyable
Magnus qui me contredit bah écoute
j'ai l'impression que tout est bien
après il y a peut-être atteint un truc
peut-être Dame des quatre intermédiaire
va voir non
je pense à moins d'aller ici
et se cacher par là peut-être genre ici
foulard
et d'un point est fou c'est 6
peut-être ça
mais bon j'aime pas enfin j'ai
l'impression que tu as tout en prise
j'aime pas les Noirs j'ai l'impression
vraiment que tu
ça va pas ça pion est toujours faible
je sais pas
je sais pas vraiment
intéressé de voir ce que Magny ça a
calculé là parce que
ça m'a l'air en fait visuellement ça m'a
l'air vraiment pas terrible ce qui nous
fait mais bon voir un truc en tout cas
quelques minutes que moi c'est clair
mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a pu voir parce que ça
m'a l'air honnêtement
moi j'aurais vite rejeté d'apprendre des
six ans j'ai vu la ligne que je vous ai
montré à la croyais fuite et il faut F5
j'aurais vite rejeter la ligne et je
pense j'aurais OK
roi des 8 apparemment c'était le seul
coup
donc je pensais à 5 maintenant
non même aussi fou le 4 peut se regarder
aussi mais peut-être un peu moins
mais bon
je bois pas trop je sais qu'on est blanc
je téléphone comme ça ma facture elle
est super il y a tout en l'air je vois
pas du tout donc été joué [__] qui
joue exactement comme moi quoi vous
imaginez que j'aurais pu avoir la même
position
Cali Raisa contre Magnus quasiment la
même
salut grosbert salut à tous bienvenue à
vous j'espère passer un agréable
dimanche soir
donc faut F5 a été joué et maintenant il
faut il faut répondre en dames et 6 ou
dame C7 ça me paraît quand même assez
passif après comment je continue si je
fais ça par exemple alors là je n'avais
pas du tout
je n'aime pas
moi je sais pas peut-être tout rose
intéressant
menace tour français 5 avec parce qu'il
y a un mal en V7 tu manges ma tour
peut-être ça c'est pas mal encore une
fois là je suis sur l'ordinateur donc je
ne sais pas ce qui se passe peut-être
pour 4 aussi en fait la position de base
elle est largement mieux pour les blancs
parce que
le roi noir se balade et que je récupère
les pions quoi qu'il arrive
donc au niveau de la sécurité du roi et
aussi l'activité des pièces les blancs
sont mille fois mieux maintenant
il faut transformer les C
donc tout reprendre la partie
et comment on termine ça Smart
ou c'est 8 ça va pas c'est lui c'est un
coup aussi moche que les carottes qui
mangent là pas je vais pousser vite il
va défoncer 600 obliger surtout ces 6
maintenant qu'est-ce que je vais faire
pas mal assez le coup c'est la partie
décidément j'avais tout des coups de
tous les coups de livraison quoi
incroyable après c'est pas très
compliqué
je m'envoie des fleurs mais c'est quand
même très logique ce qui fait un fou
Detroit X5 tours 5 c'est forcé quoi
n'importe quel débile
trouver aussi donc tu reprends le 5 ici
est très logique des 6 c'est pas
possible de reprendre des 6 n'est-ce pas
et
je sais pas comment je fais 3 ici pour
déclouer ton conseil 5 pour but
les Noirs je pense qu'il vaut même
laisser la Torré ici je pense moi j'aime
bien un coup comme moi c'est 7 on
reprend là
attention quand on pense est 5 je menace
pour prendre cette battements parce que
le Fou est clou est maintenant vous
voyez attention que recette c'est pas
forcément le meilleur coup je pensais à
un plan pour les Noirs donc je vais vous
le montrer sans la tactique d'accord on
va dire qu'on n'a pas vu ça je pense un
peu comme tour B8 donc celle là pour son
B3 pouvoir jouer à 5 jusqu'à 4 et taper
sur les pions A2 et B3 bien sûr ça
marche jamais parce qu'il y a toujours
le problème tant qu'on est 7 mais si on
arrivait à
mettre en place un truc comme ça ça
pourrait être intéressant niveau du
contre jeu pour les Noirs mais c'est
vrai que on a du mal quand même à placer
des pièces
hyper fort et très très dur en pratique
pour Magnus
si vous voulez pas avoir Rocket
je l'aurais pas fait mais c'est normal
ou pas
je vais pas aller à la rencontre de
Magnus mais
il a pensé que c'était pas mal après la
position après l'échange d'État
ne pas croquer c'est pas grave même au
contraire plein de fois c'est bien de
paroquet quand on a les changer les
dames parce qu'en finale le roi il est
de plus menacé de maths ni rien donc
Laurent l'active le roi on va le on va
le sortir un peu de sa cachette parce
que c'est une pièce active en finale
donc en fait si considéré que les
chandelle était obligatoire
et ben peut-être que il peut dire tout
simplement qu'il joue la finale et qui
s'en fout
mais ici malgré tout les pièces blanches
sont tellement actives
que j'ai vraiment du mal à trouver un
truc pour les noirs
et en fait mes pièces sont mille fois
meilleur que le thème quoi
le fou bah il est pas terrible avec ma
structure f3g2 le fuz S6 il fait que
dalle et le roi en plus au centre
c'est vraiment vraiment pas la position
de ma nièce vraiment
je mange B2 parce que je mange le fou
c'est le pire et le roi je le mets là
mais si je mets le roi là
et sur voilà ce que je B4 je te REC 5
enfin je peux j'en peux tout ce que je
veux et franchement la position on a
juste trop dur pour les Noirs je sais
pas je moi j'aime bien B4 perso
je me lasse même des fois du B5 quand
j'ai ma tour enfin
je n'aime pas du tout ce que nous fait
Magnus là
j'ai l'impression qu'il est qu'il est
hyper mal
[Musique]
je pense
même tout raciste ça n'a pas l'air
alors tu reprends ça suffit pour
s'enlever j'ai toujours tout prendre
d'ailleurs c'est un peu trique qui te
prend des sets parce que j'ai roi B6 là
tu as tout en prise
ça c'est marrant ça et je pense que du
coup tu manges du Fou en dessert
peut-être c'est un peu plus précis mais
là qu'il faut réussir à gagner le fou
mais attention attention mais si je
prends là du coup peut-être qu'il veut
tout raciste mais bon
waouh il a fait un roi de 7 ah oui c'est
vrai je suis bête évidemment je l'avais
pas pensé à recettes la tour elle est
partie le Roi peut partir de ce côté-là
OK
donc à trouver les meilleurs coups
c'était pas si compliqué en fait au
final avec un peu de recul mais ok
comment est-ce que je continue
surtout le 5 je peux avoir du Royal 6
et j'ai fou E4 sur foutran je pense
qu'il veut tourner chaque garder un
c'est joli et c'est vrai que je prends
là et ce pion F4 risque d'être perdu et
quoi qu'il arrive même si
les pièces séjournent un petit peu ben
en fait si vous regardez bien les blancs
ils ont un îlot de pion et un deuxième
îlot de pion j'ai deux idées de pions
deux groupes de pions contre un gros
plat un deuxième groupe là et un
troisième groupe là avec ce pion F4 en
plus qui est qui est qui est doublé donc
au niveau de la photo d'option et ben
les blancs sont beaucoup mieux il y a
plus de faiblesse
[Musique]
chez les Noirs donc il y a toujours un
avantage pour les blancs ici
et en pratique une erreur peut être
fatale attention c'est pas clair du tout
en tout cas mais mais quand même belle
avantage blanc ici on préfère largement
les blancs
[Musique]
c'est pas encore si facile
à jouer
à jouer par rapport au plancteur je vous
avais des élector hb8 B3 et A4 et ben
écoutez j'arrive enfin c'est cohérent ce
qu'il a fait avec à 5 ans donc tour C8
il a pas envie d'échanger comme ça
si je prends je pense qu'il faut tout
reprendre
échanger les pièces
même niveau temps il est pas très bien
mais bon ok
peut-être que ça va en fait la position
peut-être que ça va
pas trop suivi mon plan il a pas trop
fait les courses proposer
mais
moi je pense cette partie je l'aurais
pas depuis longtemps avec les Noirs
j'aurais pas réussi à
je trouvais ça dure pour le noir à 5 3 7
maintenant ça comment vouloir casser le
roi plus vite
et au final c'était assez malin ce qu'il
a fait
et puis H7 n'est pas emprise ou
attention à Madou
attention à Madou faut prendre un chèque
c'est pas possible du tout il y a un
petit piège un petit piège qui
d'ailleurs est très récurrent
ne pas manger le fou enfin le pion on
achète il y a une paille très connu
comme ça une partie de Fischer
Fisher qui est le symbole championnat du
monde entre spaski qui a mangé le pion
moi c'était pion H2 mais c'est un peu la
même idée si tu manges le pion ici il
fait bien attention à la porte qui peut
se refermer derrière toi et après j'ai
plus qu'à aller récupérer ce fou qui est
qui est perdu
donc toujours savoir si tu peux sortir
avant de rentrer
sinon à ton fou il va se retrouver
enfermé
donc tu ressens que chaque roi est fuite
c'est la partie le roi qui se cache un
petit peu
des fois mais beaucoup de fois non
beaucoup de fois non fais attention
quand même à vos pieds donc là et puis
on prend bien évidemment sur tout
reprend j'aurais perdu ce petit pion en
dessert donc pions obligatoires
tout recettes mais Magnus va pas laisser
aller faire ça je pense que s'il va je
tourner 8 ou tour de 8 qui va essayer de
vite échanger une paire de Tours
il va juste changer
mais bon les noirs qui se battent il y a
toujours ce petit plan de tour B8 B3 à 4
toujours aussi être possible donc il y a
quand même du jeu à chaque fois
la soutenant est pas si mauvaise tant
que je perds pour aller manger le pion
F4 les Noirs ont le temps d'aller
attaquer le pion B2 donc
au final
c'est pas si simple quoi
c'est ouf parce que Magnus la pollution
la valeur peut-être catastrophique pour
lui mais tous les coups par chaque fois
a été joué
ton rêve 5 j'aurais peut-être joué
autour des 8 regarder un peu ton F5 ah
tu perds un petit peu l'activité je
pense qu'autour D8 est intéressant
pourquoi parce que quand tu manges en D8
et que je mange là certes je perds un
pion mais après je m'active quoi j'ai
déjà échec voilà
mieux tourbé peut-être encore plus fort
que toi échec parce que je mange tous
les pions et ton roi il reste enfermé
sur la première rangée donc un des deux
en tout cas tu es très malin avec avec
les Blancs enfin peut-être pas mais tu
vas réussir à t'activer et ça va quoi
donc
tour des autres c'est quand même mieux
on reste on garde les pièces sur
l'attaque vraiment l'activité c'est
important donc tourner cette tour de 8 a
été joué par par Magnus là je moi je
verrai bien comme tout recette
essayer de garder comme une tour en 7e
mais après tout reprend tout reprend
je suis pas sûr de des chances de gains
de livraison moi je marque comme recette
pour prendre ton B8 B3 A4 peut-être sur
pion prend un cadre échec regardez paf
paf bon tu vas rester ici pour garder le
point F et pour là et je suis hyperactif
avec les morts je pense que noir ne
tarde jamais ça
donc tout recettes je pense parce qu'il
va se passer tour sur cette bâton s'est
vite et je pense que je vais te je vais
te harceler avec la tour
et attendre que tu prennes décision de
gâteau
en fait peut-être que c'est nul direct
après tant de
je sais pas s'il y a moyen de faire un
truc
tu reprends un 5
oui ok mais attends que je m'en fous en
fait c'est à dire que ça ça fait chèque
échec je mange là
cette finale que la gagne jamais je
t'envoie il est bloqué parce que tu
perds toutes tes chances tu le bouges
c'est assez standard je pense c'est
assez facile
non ça je pense ça va te faire nul
tranquille cette partie ça c'est la
deuxième partie du match il y a une nul
dans la première avec une pression
d'aller résa dans ce dans cette partie
tu reprends à 5 a été joué ici et bon ça
va être la même
tu reprends un centre de reprendre des
[__]
en fait au final on perd à deux donc je
pense qu'il va jouer un truc du style
tour des deux petit peu essayé tout ici
mais bon à ton tour là je prends la
elle est nulle tous les jours
tour des deux aussi c'est nul tous les
jours tout ça
je pense que maintenant il faut
limite ça peut être le blanc peut-être
qui peut être un peu en danger avec le
roi qui est un peu moins actif que le
roi noir qui peut sortir plus facilement
limite mais bon c'est nul mais je pense
que maintenant ça ireza qui va peut-être
essayer de ne pas tenter le diable
et
juste prendre la nul accepter
ton B8 mais tomber tu prends à deux
je prends à deux
mais bon l'avantage il est où
ton roi il est il sera plus jamais actif
et je monte mon roi et je vais être très
pour mettre mon roi en ces cinq des plus
beaux hasard je vois pas du tout comment
ça gagne ça et au tour G8 donc j'ai 6
aussi j'ai peut-être retour là aussi
il y a eu ton coin de tomber de
et en fait s'en fout il va manger le
pion c'est cadre tu reprends un H7 pour
C2
3 contre 3
je pense que les joueurs vont proposer
nul
vite
je pense pas que ça joue
quatre
et échec échec je pense ça va répéter
non échec on voit mal ce qui est parti
et chacun encore
et échec pure en prise tout le temps et
que je veux aussi ce qui veut dire que
sur roi des trois je pense que je peux
monter mon roi peut-être
du style roi aussi
on voit même faire H5 ou pas
si je suis
parti même 100 alors je vous rappelle
qu'il y a un délai d'une minute donc les
gens partent avant que c'est un mini
spoil à chaque fois ça mini spoil de
voir les joueurs partir on sait que la
partie terminée mais on sait pas comment
on sait que ça va faire nul mais bon
après c'est pas vraiment comment est-ce
que ça va mieux il croyait fin
répétition directe et voilà donc match
nul dans ce match on est à un partout il
y a eu deux matchs jouer et de match nul
donc on est à 1 1 je mets le score à
jour
et donc tout reste encore à jouer dans
ce match donc on a encore deux parties à
faire en 15 + 3 avec éventuellement en
armaguet donc je vous rappelle que par
rapport au bracket que je vous montre
ici et ben ce qui se passe c'est que
vous voyez que Magnus a gagné tous ces
matchs a gagné tabataba contre Furious
juin et maintenant et ben il joue la
finale donc tout gagné dans ce format là
et ben pour perdre pour être éliminé il
faut perdre deux matchs en tout donc
pour l'instant manuscrenson a perdu 0
match alors que alliation a perdu une
fois contre Karat scène en finale des
gagnants donc si Ali resa perd ce
premier match et ben ce sera terminé et
car ce sera champion de Champions Tour
donc la cinquième édition par contre il
y a les raisins gagne ce match et bien
les deux joueurs auront perdu une fois
ce qu'il veut dire qu'il y aura encore
un dernier match pour départager
les joueurs donc ça ça c'est comme ça
donc petite pause pendant que les
joueurs
se rafraîchissent un petit peu moi de
mon côté vous savez que je vais mettre
je vais vous mettre des petites pub
habituelles de nos partenaires cheescom
pour cet événement donc je vous dis à
tout de suite pour la troisième partie
[Musique]
je suis de retour donc les joueurs sont
pas encore installés on a les raisins
qui va atteindre Magnus et ça va
reprendre d'ici quelques instants
Charles 350
normalement il y a environ 5 10 minutes
de pause à chaque fois
là je sais pas combien de temps ça a
pris mais ça devrait revenir assez vite
et donc en tout cas
pour l'instant deux matchs très
intéressants cette partie j'ai beaucoup
aimé alors du coup par contre j'avais un
petit doute je vous disais pendant
plusieurs sont pas là par rapport à la
partie je suis convaincu j'avais joué
ici
ah non je suis bête je m'en souviens
j'avais joué C4
le C4 pour Julie et maintenant sa force
qu'elle avait trois c'est bien ce qui me
semble parce que si cavalier bouge
quelque part elle décide cette fois lui
il a un gros avantage parce que j'ai
peur de fou et puis je retire bêtement
froid F3 etc donc il faut jouer ici sur
cavalier sur C4 il faut que je cavalue
au 3
faut prendre et F4 je vais jouer
il avait joué un truc du style fou 7
j'avais joué foulard fou prend un grand
petit rock là
mettre le fond en C3 et on avait une
position ce type là je crois qu'il y a
du F6 full C3 ou pion prend d'abord un
truc de style on avait joué je me
souviens plus et j'avais eu un bel
avantage mais jamais jamais assez pour
vraiment gagner la partie
et puis à la fin j'étais un peu mieux et
je me suis largué un coup mais
l'ouverture intéressante en tout cas
mais qu'avec des six je me souvenais
quand un travailleur et ben c'était
le coup de l'ordinateur et aussi le coup
que je vois tous les grands joueurs
comme VR j'avais lu pas mal de parties
avec mvl pour les blancs et mais j'avais
pas osé le jouer parce que ça me
paraissait pas si simple que ça et je
voulais essayer d'enlever le jeu de
l'adversaire qu'avec la ligne que j'ai
obtenu moi et dans les noirs n'avaient
jamais enfin en vrai bazar il a jamais
eu une chance de me battre sauf quand je
me suis prendre un bâton de coup quoi
mais
je vais voir si la partie dans la base
dans la base de télescom juste pour voir
rapidement
[Musique]
faux F3 là je défile les coups
de
la base il y a une seule partie
c'est la mienne je pense je pense ma
partie ouais c'est ma partie il y a pas
marqué mon nom mais c'était ma partie
contre
comme un noob oups
Tours vous allez voir comment j'ai perdu
cette théorie
2 et là j'ai fait le prix en couple pour
prendre des 6
brillant
parce que
imparable je peux rien faire et abandon
sur le champ parce que il me laisse
échec et Nantes si je fais H3 je suis
matte comme ça en deux coups et je peux
pas empêcher ça je peux pas empêcher ça
je peux pas empêcher
d'un F2 et sur un coup qui empêcherait
la MAF 2 il aurait mal bref ça va être
terrible alors ça a repris on va aller
voir non c'est pas repris un chemin ça
part un prix vous dites des mensonges
donc j'ai perdu contre très goubof qu'on
va mettre plus de 2600 euros et j'avais
juste perdu tout seul
[Musique]
à Brest
et donc la rente 3 qui devrait démarrer
d'ici quelques instants Magnus qui va
avoir les blancs cette fois-ci donc
dernière fois qu'il aura le blanc dans
ce match
donc là les devoir essayer de
d'égaliser de ne pas perdre ce match
c'est important
alors la partie qui a pas comme ça à
l'instant j'ai la partie enfin et ça va
commencer chez nous j'ai pas encore les
pendules vous voyez mais ça va commencer
dans un instant
alors qu'est-ce que va jouer Magnus
E4 il a joué hier contre contre les
raisins c'est des belles on a vu une
nage d'orf après une Française donc
Magnus je pense que pourraient
revenir sur une sur quatre
parce que ça a bien marché hier
peut-être qu'il va vouloir repartir sur
4 E5 c'est le thème du match tout à
l'heure ça a été aussi cette même
ouverture avec le fou qui est venu en
recette d'ailleurs voilà
et par contre la caresse 3 a été jouée
au lieu de de ces trois tout à l'heure
donc l'idée c'est de venir généralement
en D5 plus tard
je sais plus comment ça marche je crois
que c'est du style B5
des 6 cavaliers des 5
non je dis n'importe quoi je crois la
ligne que ton jeu parle le fou noir est
en C5 je vous dis n'importe quoi ok
excusez-moi donc elle va laisser 3 mais
j'avais pas mal de parties comme ça avec
S3 de notamment de Sébastien Mazet qui
aime bien ce genre de petit coup
un très grand genre personnel je pense
que tout le monde le connaît sur le sur
le stream
[Musique]
le capitaine
salut GB
donc bien sûr clairement à l'IRESA il
est pas prépa c'est pas possible qui au
cinquième coup qui sortait pas donc je
pense qu'il en connaissait de en train
d'essayer de
choisir quel plan il va utiliser pour
jouer cette partie
je pense que jamais ma twitch la réponse
est jamais je pense pas
en tout cas vous n'avez pas vous n'aurez
pas d'erreur tout j'aime avec moi parce
que
juste
je le sais tout simplement je le sais
je le sais trop dur bien trop dur
devient grand maître en fait entre
maître et grand maître les niveaux il
est tellement
tellement de grosse différence qu'en
fait
donc non non non
petit rock a été joué ici
[Musique]
donc il y a plusieurs alors il y a un
piège surtout pas faire je crois que
c'est T4
des 4 puis on prend caballer prend
cavaler prend d'arme prend C5 suivi de
C4 c'est un piège hyper connu dans
l'espagnol attention le fou serait perdu
donc bien évidemment
ma tenue de la page des quatre donc il y
a eu des trois de jouer
[Musique]
pourquoi pas mais moi je sais que je ne
travaille plus l'échec à la maison j'ai
plus long j'ai plus envie j'ai plus
envie j'ai plus la niaque
donc
je ne vais même pas essayer
ça vous pouvez en être sûr après le jour
où je passe 24 5 ans et que j'ai un
éloigne de ce nom peut-être que voilà
même 24 50 ça reste encore autre chose
et comme je travaille plus l'échec je
pense pas arriver enfin je pense pas
progresser si je travaille pas quoi
donc non grand maître puis c'est
beaucoup c'est tellement de temps à
travailler et au final pour pas grand
chose ça ne m'apportait absolument rien
à me connaître dans ma vie donc
je veux pas mettre c'est bien je suis
content c'est déjà cool mais après plus
non je pense que j'ai atteint j'ai
atteint mon niveau max
et
[Musique]
ouais
l'autre jour on en parle un stream je
crois que c'est je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est au Japon en fait ou
aller les
la Fédération japonaise ou en Corée bon
je sais plus un des pays là-bas
qui donnait des sortes de
retraite à vie pour les joueurs qui
étaient pro au Go en jeu de goût et en
fait quand tu passes professionnels
toute ta vie et ben tu reçois de
l'argent tous les mois qui te permet de
pouvoir vivre et jouer des tournois etc
et donc si on avait ça aux échecs en
France je peux vous garantir que les
échec serait bien populaire qui aurait
beaucoup plus d'argent dans les échecs
il y a beaucoup plus de joueurs qui
essaient de passer grand maître et si on
met si jamais on faisait ça en France et
ben écoutez ma vision des choses
pourrait peut-être changer je vous dirai
bon matin peut-être stouf tu vas essayer
de passer mais bon là actuellement je
m'en fous
absolument aucune envie voilà
et donc là à lirasa qui a donné le pion
au 5 est-ce que c'est normal
je vois qui n'aime pas du tout et
souvent on fait d'abord des savoir-faire
cavaler à 5
donc là il a raison de donner ce pion
donc certes tu gagnes la paire de fou je
suis d'accord
mais un pion simple en plus
alors c'est quoi la raison là même si
j'ai quand même cavaler c'est 6
fourchette qui rend la part de fou donc
je
[Musique]
suis pas du dessus très j'aime pas ce
qui a fait ici bon dessin que doit être
logique il y a encore qui a été si
simple
il y a encore ça en fait
c'est un peu chiant d'apprendre
juste pas quoi
quelqu'un n'arrête ou pas de ce qu'il a
fait qu'elle va les prendre à 5 là
il est parti comme ça
et une partie
une seule partie comme ça ça va être
égal noir
malheureusement je peux pas savoir qui
c'est là
je vais essayer d'ouvrir la côte
2000 quoi ok super c'est un jour à 2000
qui a le sac noir
[Musique]
écouter je sais pas je sais pas
alors on peut tourner le chéquier
Théodore mais le problème c'est que si
on connaîthée et ben vous allez voir les
temps sur moi j'ai vraiment
mes scènes dans Obs quand tu as créé
pour changer à chaque fois de couleur
mais si je vous tourne vous voyez qu'il
est temps sont moches tu as noir sur
blanc c'est pour ça que je tourne pas
pour l'instant mais dites-moi s'il y a
au préféré vraiment que je tourne je
tourne et au final je pense que l'on
s'habitue à ça si vous voulez je reste
comme ça si vous voulez je tourne ce
sera moche mais
c'est la raison pour laquelle je tourne
pas et je laisse comme ça en fait parce
qu'à la base je suis d'accord qu'on
préfère suivre un joueur et on préfère
tourner le chèque à chaque fois mais là
en fait le problème c'est que leur
scène Obs c'est le petit problème quoi
je peux pas changer
voilà
un peu voir un peu
comment les raisins va continuer donc la
dessin qu'on va être joué c'est sûr il
faut que je descends il faut ouvrir la
position il faut essayer
d'utiliser les fous vous savez quand
j'ai la paire de fou il faut absolument
absolument
ouvrir la position donc D5 qui en prend
d'un temps et mettre les fous sur les
diagonale etc il faut absolument ouvrir
la position donc ça m'avait l'air assez
logique et oui c'est ça que de la part
d'aller raisin ok il prend le empêche
des cadres ils imaginent plus de 5 va
arriver
très très vite est-ce que Kevin est en
vacances je ne sais pas je sais pas du
tout
donc encore une fois à l'air sympa
mais j'ai envie de jouer des cinq mais
bon il y a un pion au moins quand même
on a vu ma news qui a fait une Mimi il y
a quelques secondes donc on a une minute
de décalage peut-être qu'il a fait un
coup dont il est pas content pendant ce
temps-là mais je sais pas là j'aime bien
les blancs perso
j'aime bien les blancs il y a un truc en
plus ça arrive pas à voir les
compréhension là j'arrive pas à voir les
compenser
la Coupe du Monde bah je n'ai pas envie
j'imagine
sinon il serait allé
C4 jouer par Magnus
donc C4
ok ça garde bien la case des 5 donc
c'est 4 c'est un bout que j'aime bien
alors pourquoi j'aime bien je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que comme tout à
l'heure je vous disais avec la part de
fou il faut qu'on arrive à ouvrir la
position de nos fous et dans les potions
ouvertes les fonctions meilleures et
dans la boisson fermée les cavaliers
sont meilleurs du coup en jouant ces
quatre qui a joué pardon qui a joué ici
Magnus et ben je vais réussir votre
cavaler en dessin plus tard peut-être
mais en tout cas les fous voyez ils vont
moins réussir à bouger parce que j'ai
pas réussi à faire descendre j'ai pas
réussir à vraiment ouvrir la position
centrale donc j'ai bien ce petit coup C4
maintenant il faut voir est-ce que je
peux jouer des Français 3 vous savez
quand un pion fait deux cases d'un trou
et ben j'ai le droit de faire la prise
en passant donc est-ce que je peux
manger là et dire bon bah tiens il y a
ça
mais bon je sais pas
je sais pas
je sais pas s'il faut manger ou pas mais
vu la position bah écoutez j'en ai
plutôt bien
les blancs est-ce que les Noirs ont
tendre amener un cavalier à quelque part
[Musique]
parce que je pourrais mettre un fond à 6
ce sera donc avaler de prendre des 4 en
main d'oeuvre c'est un peu long mais
standard aussi comme système comme plan
avec les cavaliers après on 5
mais bon il y a un pion de plus pour les
blancs mais sur le long terme il y a la
paire de fou donc peut-être que à
l'IRESA va réussir à faire un truc mais
bon c'est un pion quand même après c'est
pas non plus un super pion mais aussi un
pion aéré en racisme
à 5 a été joué
il peut aussi plus tard se garder une 4
pourquoi pas un jour tour 1
et
comment est-ce qu'on termine
pour jouer A4
poussé à 4 mais j'ai aussi G6 c'est fou
G7 qui est clairement aussi un plan
intéressant avec ce fou qui va s'ouvrir
sur la diagonale donc avoir vraiment
comment comment ça se joue
quand même 6 minutes de retard aussi
c'est pas négligeable aussi
je sais que je vais pas le 5
à la place de jouer ce que j'avais dit
là
je sais pas mais bon dans tous les cas
j'ai envie d'ouvrir la position enfin
j'ai envie de sortir mes fous j'ai envie
de mettre pépion en centre quoi mais
j'en sais rien moi je connais rien cette
position juste je donne mon opinion
quand on a quand on a la barre de fou il
faut essayer d'ouvrir il faut essayer de
faire ça donc c'est prendre des 5 c'est
un coucou n'aime pas du tout
l'ordinateur mais j'aurais certainement
jouer aussi super cavalier en C4 un
cavaliers qui pourrait être vraiment
très très bien sur cette case en C4 et
pourquoi est-ce que l'ordinateur n'aime
pas alors je vais tricher je vais
allumer l'ordinateur une petite seconde
pour voir
H6 meilleur coup ouais super
apparemment sous les 5 c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment le bon coup et qu'est-ce
qui se passe alors si moi je vais battre
mon cavaler les deux
ouais bon le plan change bien quoi en
fait
ce qui m'énerve
F6 et si j'avais joué comme d'hab c'est
car elle est venue en C4 c'est un peu la
même chose de jouer
donc
j'aime pas du tout la position
malheureusement
ça sent très mauvais regardez quel allié
des deux ça va essayer
donc J5 on est obligé en fait de faire
des trucs des coups bizarres tellement
l'impulsion est pas vraiment donc
fougères probablement
le fou qui est pas forcément bon et ce
qui prend là je prends les fous
s'ouvrent c'est intéressant donc
peut-être que foug-3 c'est pas bon
avoir mais
[Musique]
qui est fou toi peut-être du coup faut
trois si je vends des deux j'ai plus le
cavalier 2 pour me lancer 4 il y a
embouteillage sur la case 2 ou 3
peut-être pas mal pour venir la la
et après revenir mais voyez le fait
d'avoir changé
un jour
donc chaque coup noir c'est quand même
un coup qui arrive la position
mais il faut le faire parce que ben il
est mal donc il faut qu'il arrive à
jouer des coups
actif quoi donc il faut faire des choses
je pensais à justice qu'elle a moche
mais je veux faire F5 en fait je vais
essayer d'ouvrir la position d'ouvrir
mon four en fait
maintenant il faut prendre donc ça pas
du tout j'ai quatre été joué ok encore
plus agressif
j'ai qu'à toi
et après puis on prend
et puis
est-ce que Magnus va donner le pion
ce qui va le gagner de ce serait beau ce
serait beau donner le pion faire G3
[Musique]
on s'en fout complètement
ce serait beau en vrai c'est intéressant
j'ai encore des choses
je pense que c'est un bon
je pense c'est un bon coup je te triste
il y a un problème quand même sur le
clouage du mal à m'enlever du clouage
j'ai pu acheter
madame je peux pas virer de vous
c'est vrai que cavalier des deux malins
intéressant je sais pas du tout si c'est
possible
il a pris G4 et on voit le pion qui
était enfin le cookie était en orange
orange couleur carotte
prise sous prend et maintenant il y a un
problème quand même pratique sur un sur
le faux F3
écoutez je pense que pour ma part je
pense que c'est où on n'a jamais été le
mieux que maintenant on avait aussi bien
dans cette position que maintenant et
ici après après faut prendre je 4 il a
laissé il faut prendre F3 qui va être
joué je pense très vite par
Ali resa à moins qu'ils ont encore F5
qui voit vraiment aller jusqu'au bout
sortir le mois prochain c'est le fou
comment sortira
sortir droit pour chasser le fou je vois
pas comment tu voulais
mais la prise prise F5 la dame qui va
arriver de train H4 un jour
mais le roi il a c'est bien calme
défendu en O2
là j'ai quand même une belle une belle
cabane avec mes pions
ça a l'air quand même du solide pour
pour Magnus donc là il y a quand même du
jeu ça y est je crois qu'il y a les
raisins il a réussi à trouver un peu de
jeu
et la position et ben écoute elle est
pas si simple au final parce qu'il y a
B2 en l'air j'ai des fois dû à 4 pour
ouvrir encore plus la position
et et livraison qui calme et même F4
aussi est un coup
si je fais F4
[Musique]
et ben je peux presque prétendre à ce
que mon fou sa meilleure que le tien
et donc comme j'ai un plan de moins avec
les blancs avec les Noirs pardon j'ai un
peu moins mais peut-être que en
comparaison vous voyez et ben je peux te
dire bon bah j'ai un peu moins mais j'ai
un meilleur fou
et donc ça peut être chaud la tour à
deux m'avait la logique pour défendre ça
et rester aussi en contact depuis un 5
pour 32 c'est un coûtait c'est pas un
goût très actif mais bon je pense qu'il
faut quand même défendre ce pion sinon
je le mange je pense que je vais je vais
le manger
[Musique]
donc
je commence à bien aimer les Noirs même
si un jour dit le contraire quand même
je trouve que c'est intéressant
c'est quoi voter hello à votre élo
à tomber ok je préfère je préfère garder
contact sur le pion ici donc étant bien
et la jauge qui
aime pas trop hein ça coûte trop bien ça
coupe passif maintenant si on compare la
les pièces de chaque camp vous voyez
qu'en fait les pièces noires sont plus
actives que les pièces blanches
les tours joue pas trop le roi est un
peu en vadrouille et j'ai du FK aussi
qui peut être pas mal
voilà jauge un peu du mal à côté des
fois parce que franchement la meuf trois
j'aime bien
attention
ça empêche trois ou deux
et puis ça menace des petites choses ça
ça me permet de pouvoir essayer regarder
ramenez une tour peut-être ou un fou ou
un truc il a fait la F3 et l'ordinateur
n'aime pas du tout il m'a écouté et la
jauge qui n'aime pas mon coup pourquoi
il n'aime pas mon cou je comprends rien
quand même pas mal en quoi secouer pas
bon aidez-moi
va partir plus vite en fait un F3 ça va
aider des blancs à attaquer je comprends
mieux
une fois qu'on voit le film on prend
mieux et pas me prendre bien a été le
coup joué par Ali resa donc c'est un
coup assez quand même assez
sérieux parce que là du coup il échange
de moi et bon il a pu passer c'est pas
si clair encore mais maintenant la
position de Magnus mais qui avait quand
même le roi un petit peu au centre et
ben on va s'améliorer complètement parce
que c'est une finale et quand le roi il
est au centre avec
finale et ben c'est beaucoup moins grave
que c'était un milieu de jeu donc par
principe j'aurais bien aimé essayer de
garder les dames parce que le roi blanc
est toujours un peu faible mais la
finale maintenant
et ben car ça va pouvoir essayer de
presser un peu donc moi j'avais un petit
roi à deux c'était un jour c'est de
faire F3 pour les conceptions et je veux
des quatre
pour essayer de changer les pions et
changer les fous etc il faut F4 pas mal
aussi attaque des 6
et c'est chaud comment est-ce qu'on joue
la foule
c'est trop facile ça parle même pas
c'est pas si fort de 8 c'est la partie
mais c'est pas si
donc je suis pas sûr que Magnus fasse B3
pendant tous les cas c'est vrai que il y
a toujours un problème c'est la partie
mais maintenant j'ai l'impression quand
même que les noirs sont assez actifs on
peut imaginer un coup comme un tour à
deux et plus tard tout refuite avec la
tour il y aurait F2 derrière un fou qui
pourrait venir en D4 dans un monde
parfait j'arriverai à mettre mes deux
tours et mon fou sur pion F2 mais sauf
que Magnus va pas laisser les raisins
être vraiment parfait
et c'est vrai que si je peux la tour à
deux Tourer quatre ça pourrait être pas
mal pour les noirs
en pratique c'est pas si facile pour
Magnus
que je crois
tourner
je pense qu'il a dû vouloir éviter avec
les avec les Blancs donc 3 2 tu aurais
fuite logique autour des bons ici il
part activer l'autre
le foutart donc en E3 ou en G3
c'est bien ok c'est la partie
comment je continue une tête T4 un jour
pour le lance apporte une menace afin
d'échanger toutes les pièces les pions
les fous
faire un peu le ménage
et salut c'est cigogne salut à toi
[Musique]
c'est cigogne qui nous revient de l'Alpe
d'Huez
qui a joué le championnat féminin
[Musique]
j'en ai marre je crois que je vais
enlever les feedbacks
ça m'énerve
alors faut 5
comment sont comptés
par contre si je fais ici D4 puis on
prend souper il faut prendre tout
reprendre vous voyez qu'il y a un petit
problème qui pour arriver c'est à la fin
je peux avoir un petit tour à deux
attaque F2 derrière et sur un coup comme
par exemple tourner deux ben il y aurait
tout reprend suite au point de ou
l'inverse je t'attends sur le fait mais
il y aura un problème c'est pas encore
possible ici F4 non plus
l'ordi oui l'ordinateur il est
insupportable en fait il m'énerve parce
que la position elle est pas compliquée
et lui un mauvais coup à chaque fois
enfin ça va quoi
parce que ça empêche sa tour à deux sur
le long terme ça me permet de pouvoir
faire tourger un et peut-être un jour
faire F4 et essayer de m'organiser sans
qui est tout à deux alors tu vois c'est
toujours un coup qui peut venir embêter
en Bété des blancs dans plein de
variantes j'aime bien ça
n'empêche les Noirs s'active de
s'activer et après on va progresser
peut-être même tout refait quatre il est
une possibilité
non j'aime bien aussi tours j'ai un
échec roi H8 puis peut-être tourgé 4
pour jouer à F4 peut-être c'est plus
précis que t'aurais fait parce que
la torréative ici droit il est mal placé
en H8
non j'aime bien ici et j'aime bien que
c'est ton géant par contre pour géant
pour G7 non je prends les 4
attention quand même tour géant regardez
ce que je viens de dire là je viens de
dessin pour pour voir mais en fait il y
a souvent un tour à trois qui peut
servir derrière l'option il est pas
défendable
pas venir ici donc attention que c'est
pas si facile il y a peut-être encore du
contre-jeu il faut encore un petit peu
attention aux petits pions B3 c'est la
tour n'a pas partir
et donc c'est croix avantages blancs
mais faut toujours faire attention
tu vas faire attention c'est pas si
facile
à tourger un roi et fuite ouais faut
voir hein
ce que je peux jouer des trucs
tous les cas en fait je l'avais dit pour
avant quand c'était comme ça donc
c'était pas une option
et la tour géant mais avec ton géant
maintenant ça laisse plus tard tour à
trois
ça peut le laisser
donc je suis pas sûr que ton géant soit
vraiment le coup le plus
[Musique]
le plus précis en plus avec ton rejet un
peu posé
et aussi mon roi qui peut s'activer ou
revenir un peu et peut-être que du coup
ça va aider les Noirs à améliorer les
pièces peut-être que ton chien c'est pas
le meilleur coup
[Musique]
extrêmement importante le vainqueur de
la partie prend une grosse option sur la
finale
Tour Eiffel
tour C2 a été joué pas trop l'idée un
jour de faire un D4 et rentrer par
là-bas je vois un truc comme ça mais je
suis pas sûr de tout
roi et fut a été joué quasi tempo
alors des casques
mais je pense pas que ça met quelque
chose je pensais à un truc de style et
chèque voilà échec vous voyez un truc
comme ça quoi
mais bon il y a fuyé 6 j'ai plein de
trucs je suis pas sûr que ça amène
quelque chose mais au pire des cas sur
des cas je pense que je m'en fous
prendre des quatre
et je suis pas sûr
tu auras deux donc ça marchera pas elle
me tourner est pas mal aussi je sais pas
c'est une option en tout cas vu que tu
as fait de tour C2
on peut se demander pourquoi et des cas
je pense que c'est une idée qui pourrait
qui pourrait arriver
un tour de 4 et
ça a l'air quand même d'être un bon pion
de plus pour pour les blancs
je t'y prends du pion c'est quoi la réfe
exactement et chaque je pensais aller
ici mais il y a tourgé un qui me fait un
peu peur
mais prise et chaque roi là ça c'est
quoi la
c'est quoi
et chaque là
que je dois venir à la
je vois pas
de trucs qui crève les yeux mais je le
vois pas
je le vois pas
j'ai pas l'ordi
on va le voir en fait la partie
maintenant
tous les deux waouh ok bon je t'ai pas
du tout là alors
que j'ai un grand
je suis curieux
ok bon trop dur
il y a eu fou ici direct ils gardent
l'option ici au cas où il y a aussi le
problème actuellement mais quatre donc
H5 il a raison les raisins il faut
pousser des pions
donc la récupérer le pion mais il a tout
en l'air la structure la gamme très
mauvaise et le fou maintenant est
mauvais depuis que le pion est passé en
tout rachat aussi est un couple je pense
que je vais me tourner
qui peut être très embêtant surtout ici
j'aurais D3 échecs qui va récupérer la
tour
la tour qui a du mal à partir en H1 à
cause de tour à toi tout le temps
je sens que c'est la partie
de 40 contre 45 secondes pour aller
raisin échec croix G7 la jauge qui
n'aime pas ça
c'est tendu 45 secondes mais bon il y a
quand même un crémant et puis les
raisins amulette ça va et ce qu'il fait
tu vois quand tu vas lire les raisins
Magnus ou avec 45 secondes en vrai
c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas si grave quoi
les joueurs jouent très très vite ils
ont l'habitude donc je pense que ça va
encore
c'est le weekend
panique pour lui ouais après oui c'est
vrai que c'est mieux qu'il est plus de
temps mais après ça va c'est pas le pire
quoi ambulette c'est quand même pas le
pire des joueurs donc ça va en fait
donc Roger 16 comment on continue avec
les Blancs alors ton géant il y a
toujours ce problème ouais
je sais qu'un jour je peux toujours
faire tourner à 3 quoi entre trois trucs
concrets ils m'ont fou quand même pour
plein de cases donc c'est pas facile
vraiment de venir me cacher enfin me
chercher
je crois direct oui aussi peut-être que
c'est une possibilité de manger plus
rien F2 mais là je vais maintenant
pouvoir manger le pion MP3 quoi ça
pourrait être pas mal
après on sait pas si vraiment les les
blancs peuvent aussi manger des pâtes
mais là P4 là ici à échec avec un gros
problème là et sur tous les deux j'ai
fout les quatre bon vous voyez c'est
quand même complexe
3 2
et en fait bah là c'est pas clair
c'est pas clair il y a plus mais écoutez
j'ai un bon fou j'ai un peu passé
et puis j'ai un pion qui est passé aussi
en détroit qui peut toujours faire un
petit surprise
je trouve que la pollution elle est pas
claire du tout en fait
ah oui ambulette les gens pour des trucs
que nous on voit même pas partie lente
je suis d'accord qu'ils sont extrêmement
impressionnants ces joueurs
moi j'avais vu mvl faire du Bullet avec
Jules en IRL
et c'était juste un spectacle quand tu
les voyais jouer tu dis mais en fait
ils sont beaucoup trop fort quand même
en fait
ils arrivent à trouver des coups trouver
des idées avec 5 secondes à la pendule
mais c'était pas humain quoi et c'est
énorme c'était il y a très longtemps
sur Paris
alors ton G5 T3 on va manger je pense le
pion F2 donc le pion à 5 qui va tomber
mais là il y a un clouage ici et aussi
P3 qui peut toujours partir je vous
rappelle que c'était le thème tout à
l'heure
donc attention il va y avoir un échec je
pense plutôt en H6 je regarde droit G7
car d'un œil sur
sur la tour
comment on termine ça
alors au niveau de temps 40 secondes
contre 21
avant-hier 3 0 entre les joueurs 3-0
pour pour Magnus et pour l'instant c'est
c'est
deux parties nulles d'affilée genre plus
de temps
32 secondes contre 17 secondes
si l'échec c'est quand même de fou
[Musique]
si
je comprends pas ta question
ok
prise et tu auras 3 il y avait toujours
roi C4 qui venait après manger le pion
B4 il faut garder le clouage je pense
c'est important
fou ou 3 OK
tour H3
la chose qui n'aime pas ça
manger et pas mal aussi
quatre secondes pour Magnus orage 5
jouets
le fou qui est tombé
un pion de plus sec le roi pas les
manger les 4 maintenant peut-être que
c'est terminé en fait
c'est terminé en fait juste fou ici fou
ici on va changer les pièces le pion qui
va tomber la fenêtre qui est l'arcane
très très dur à jouer tour H3 à une
seconde tombée tour ici fousset 3 foot
des 4
et je pense abandon quasiment on peut
rien faire on reprend ici on ramène le
roi
et moi je vais monter mon roi jusqu'en
C6 a priori pousser le pion
et je vois pas comment Magnus peut ne
pas la gagner ici
ça a l'air foutu
qui est parti
donc la partie est terminée mais on sait
pas encore quel résultat mais on peut
imaginer que
tu as les raisins
attention la jauge qui descend
on n'est jamais sûr
bref attention ah ça c'était trop un qui
peut arriver
on prend un 4 attention
waouh qui a complètement changé
une bonne nouvelle peut-être une bonne
nouvelle peut-être
ok cette position est perdante
alors je vais vous montrer il y a eu il
y a eu une huile de rater mais avec peu
de temps la pendule c'est juste
impossible de trouver un trouvable
regardez juste avant il y a une ligne de
rater moi j'avais l'ordinateur pour la
fin de partie mais bon avec 5 secondes à
la pendule comment voulez-vous trouver
roi des trois qui est d'ailleurs non et
il dit que ça gagne moi il me dit nul et
quand je le joue il me dit que ça gagne
ok encore une fois l'ordinateur super
avec sa jauge
je pensais que ça ça pourrait faire
mieux c'est juste perdant ok bah écoutez
grosse partie de ma niche dans ce
troisième partie du 7
donc on va quand même avoir la dernière
partie du match avec un gain
pour aller résa obligatoire obligatoire
pour aller résa de gagner cette partie
avec les Blancs donc il va quand même
les blancs si elle gagne cette partie on
va avoir droit à un Armageddon et il
sera obligé de gagner un magazon pour
aller dans le deuxième set contre Magnus
donc petit âge de pub pour vous montrer
un petit peu les sponsors et les
partenaires de l'événement je vous dis à
tout de suite
[Musique]
et je suis de retour alors les joueurs
qui vont
s'installer prendre place pour
la quatrième partie du match donc avec
un score que je vais vous mettre à jour
maintenant de 2-1 pour Magnus qui vient
de gagner cette partie avec les Blancs
donc agréa avec les noirs est obligé de
gagner pour pour forcer l'Armageddon et
donc le départ
si elle est pas cette partie des blancs
et ben le match sera terminé et il
arrivera deuxième donc ça va reprendre
en quelques instants là donc le joueur
arrive
je dirais d'ici deux minutes à peu près
ça va reprendre
donc allez
avec les Blancs il peut faire un truc
franchement il est pas ridicule dans le
match il a vraiment fait des grosses
parties et je pense qu'il est clairement
capable
de revenir dans le match et de battre
Magnus Carson
ce serait beau en tout cas un petit
come-back d'aller raisin
[Musique]
et donc s'il arrive à gagner cette
partie puis l'Armageddon et ben il
forcerait un deuxième set qui serait
le dernier match du championnat donc
fatigué je pense que vous en pensez mais
je trouve fatigué ma muse
pour l'instant oui
zen il avait perdu 3-0 la première fois
donc là il y a eu deux nuls et une
défaite c'est bien mieux que la première
fois même si
même si ok on préférerait que
le match se déroule quand même autrement
ça c'est
c'est clair alors la partie est lancée
donc j'ai Ali raisin avec les Blancs
contre Magnus Carson avec les noirs
j'ai la position je pense que le genre
ont commencé et vous savez qu'on a une
minute de décalage avec les caméras donc
les gens ont déjà commencé à la partie
et nous on a une minute de moins donc
quand la partie commencera chez nous ça
fera une minute que la partie on va
commencer chez eux donc il y a toujours
un petit délai
les raisins qu'est-ce qu'il va nous
jouer plutôt le cas je pense
je pense plutôt que 4
un peu sous mamie va nous faire alors
Magnus tout à l'heure même depuis le
début du tournoi et ben il y a d'humeur
à jouer quand même des Celiane
qui est plutôt cool parce que ça ouvre
le jeu et
du coup enfin les raisins a besoin de
gagner une partie donc un jeu ouvert ce
serait quand même plutôt sympa plutôt
intéressant
4 c'est la partie et c'est ça encore une
fois ça respecte tout ce qu'on a le
début et B3 a été joué donc la Magnus
qui est un peu surpris et qui
et qui
qui sort un petit peu battu là B3 pour
jouer
tous les deux d'écart
comment est-ce qu'on va reprendre un jeu
il me semble à me souvenir très lointain
qu'un très bon coup sur B3 c'est B6
pourquoi parce qu'en fait avec
rapidement on va réussir à attaquer le
pion à 4 et donc à forcer les blancs de
défendre par exemple je prends un truc
débile si je joue un truc comme ça tous
les deux et que je sors mes pièces et
baleines blancs vont réussir à rajouter
des quatre cavaler prendre des quatre
tous les trois pardon 3 et blanc vont
réussir à avoir une position assez
confortable alors que si on joue B6 ou
B2 B7 tu as moins la possibilité pour un
jeu de 4 à cause de du pion à 4 Detroit
c'est pas trop ce que je veux faire et
qu'avec ces trois bah on n'est jamais
sûr si le cavalier va là ou pas ou s'il
fait d'abord C4 bref dans tous les cas
il me semblait à l'époque quand je
travaille un peu les échecs que le coup
B6 était un des coût
qu'on m'avait conseillé de jouer et deux
joueurs qui rigolent
[Musique]
on a eu les joueurs se regarder en
rigolant alors je sais pas pourquoi je
me demande si à livrer une carotte ce
serait marrant de voir ranger une
carotte ça serait un peu troll par
rapport à Magnus ce serait vraiment de
bonne guerre mais est-ce que vraiment il
mange une carotte il mange un truc hein
c'est pas ce qui mange mais il mange un
truc
et je pense que maxi troll ça pourrait
être vraiment la carotte la carotte pour
[Musique]
pour aller raisin
mort des chips OK
en vrai ça pourrait être drôle la
carotte
ça fait trois minutes
qu'il
réfléchit c'est pas quoi faire
moi je pense que les 6 c'était le coup
que j'avais à l'époque et je pense que
tout est jouable des 5 doivent jouer
aussi qu'avec les 6 voilà tout tout doit
être ok donc descendre je pense que la
réponse générale c'est prise de 4
[Musique]
parce que là je pense qu'il peut jouer à
part OK
prise rock ou prise des cadres d'abord
je ne sais pas mais il en vouloir jouer
le contrôle isolé et c'est très très
standard comme
comme
pose donc ca va les prendre les 7 a été
joué
puis on prend c'est encore plus envie
que qu'avant parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'avec ça on va réussir quand même
échec faire des quatre et à manger un
jour en C5 pour créer ce petit pion
isolé en dessin
je vois un peu ce genre d'idées
rock
en plus je vous rappelle qu'il y a eu il
y a eu des points de chaîne en jeu de
miser dans un match donc on va voir un
petit peu les points de chaîne
qui a beaucoup de points de chaîne qui
sont en jeu
dans ce dans ce set
petit rock
a été joué et là on peut imaginer de
tour info est-ce que ton tournoi fou au
7 j'ai pas des idées comme d'habitude
qui pourrait être rigolo alors regardez
en fait l'idéal qu'avec ça et dans les
noirs peuvent plus roquet
du rock je prends le fou
et du coup c'est c'est un peu
handicapant
peut-être jouer même fois trois
peut-être intéressant aussi même des
cartes même cavaler cette fois
mais je sais pas si c'est possible
mais il a pas le choix de cette gamepad
il y aurait des trois
donc
il y a eu des
[Musique]
que je proposais et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on roi est fuite pour se déro enfin
pour se déclouer
c'est quand même pas la bonne nouvelle
non plus
est-ce que j'ai pas un cavalier fuite
aussi pour essayer de colmater mais bon
faut à trois me fait peur
vous voyez
Descartes qui me fait peur aussi il y a
plein de trucs qui me font peur
ok c'est un peu lent mais bon on va voir
ça ça
je sais pas ça me paraît long tout ça
mais attention Magnus parce que
ça peut vite se retourner quand même
[Musique]
X à 3 et quand ça va tous les coups sont
tous les coups on a bien
en fait l'idée de dégâts c'est que tu
prends je prends j'ai cavalier F5 un peu
ce qui peut arriver
peut être sympa
tu prends pas bah je peux manger là
sortir les pièces et ça peut aller assez
vite quand même
4 et F5
alors cavalue 4 c'est quand même qui
avait des deux attention de pas mais F5
c'est un coup qui est quand même
très comment dire responsable t'as pas
ok tout le Pione
j'ai plus le foot de case blanche donc
peut-être mais c'est osé hein c'est oser
quand même
c'est très osé
peut-être c'est le coup
mais comment va jouer ici là j'ai froid
donc attention on a pris le 4 ça va être
là il y a des vis-à-vis un peu de
partout
moi je pensais à tour c'est 6 mais ça
l'art bizarre
mais je sais pas du tout ce que ce que
ça vaut
là
qui défend c'est 5 mais juste en de mes
pièces moi
c'est quand même le problème de la
position
[Musique]
avoir même force
tours
des problèmes de partout même si tu
arrives à roquer
j'ai quand même des clouages de partout
c'est pas évident pour moi
c'est pas évident du tout écouter j'aime
beaucoup la pose de lire les
j'aime beaucoup la pose de lire les
raisins je me serais bien
je me serais bien sur lui
on est obligé on a pas le choix on n'a
pas le choix il faut mis sur les raisins
pour cette partie mais
je trouve qu'il a vraiment une bonne
position
avoir une bonne pause
et ben vu ce qui fait bien la gueule
3 et F8
c'est dur aussi
cavaler aussi
mais ça ça à la fin c'est comme toujours
dans le dessin qui est vraiment
[Musique]
très très dur à prononcer il y a deux un
deux un pour Magnus donc deux nuls puis
une
défaitea c'est la dernière partie de ce
set en cas d'égalité ou de victoire de
Magnus et pas Magnus gagne le tournoi si
à lireza gagne cette partie il y aura un
Armageddon sur enchères pour gagner ce 7
et avec victoire obligatoire encore une
fois dans les raisins pour forcer le
dernier 16 donc là les raisins il est
vraiment dos au mur il faut qu'il fasse
Gargant quoi
il y aura encore un 7
à 6 donc on a vu que il y avait une idée
avec ton la tour là il y avait très
gênant donc je pense que à 6 ça empêche
d'embais 5 et maintenant cavalier c'est
trois alors pas mal du tout ça continue
à sortir de pièces j'aime bien il y a
aussi des quatre qu'elle a pas mal vous
voyez ça ouvre ça ça confirme à mettre
la pression sur le sur le four 7
[Musique]
dangereux car cavalier F3 et D4 ouais
mais bon je mangerai pas moi je pense
qu'une personne il a pas envie de manger
donc
à Tours peut venir tranquillement
un gros problème de Magnus là qui arrive
pas ok
donc comment est-ce qu'on concrétise
avec les Blancs est-ce qu'un coup alors
je vous propose un truc bizarre
[Musique]
mais est-ce comme ces cartes qui a l'air
débile et possible
j'ai vu une tactique sur D4
et je mange là
et du coup c'est quatre mon idée c'est
que je veux vraiment ouvrir le centre
radar cavalier et tu peux pas manger si
tu prends je pousse enfin je prends je
fais camel est là là j'arrive vraiment à
tout ouvrir en même temps donc C4 c'est
un coup car à première vue qui a l'air
ou ça a été joué quel génie ça a été
joué donc c'est un coup qui est à
première vue je disais ça avait l'air
complètement
en petits positionnel mais en fait qui
est assez intéressant du coup c'est 4
et
des quatre qui avaient les prendre des
quatre
bien sûr on voit les on voit les
vis-à-vis moi je vois que ça vis-à-vis
et là je vois pas intéressé trois la
force aussi franchement cette pollution
elle est un joueur pour les Noirs
complètement
complètement jouable non je pense qu'il
a ouvert le stream évidemment
à côté il a mis un petit son tout petit
pas qu'on le démasque mais je pense
franchement que que les raisins il nous
écoute et c'est pour ça qu'il a tous les
coups
il a une belette il a une belle Ada être
aidé partout c'est quand même la classe
en vrai
salut gros dan
[Musique]
ah ouais
sous l'écran et franchement
dès que je vais la pose je bouffe un
petit morceau après tout le temps en
pause mais à la carotte c'est la vie
nous a remarqué que l'autre diamant sur
le site 125 euros alors que si quelqu'un
vous l'offre elle est à 111 et ben quoi
on a la vie il faut avoir des amis donc
ça
il faut avoir des amis alors ces quatre
a été joué
et comment est-ce que va répondre Magnus
pas facile
c'était une idée pardon il y a quelqu'un
même B5
donc
une fois reste clairement
la pression ici alors ca va aller aussi
se va être quand même
[Musique]
le coup le coup de Magnus des 4 hyper
logique je peux pas manger parce qu'il y
a ça ouais tu manges en Descartes quoi
donc du coup tu peux pas je peux pas du
tout
[Musique]
salut Pat ça va
non mais si tu joues des 4
c'est perdu
[Musique]
sur le sur le truc si tu mangerais bien
sûr tes maths etc mais du coup j'ai fait
cavaler des quatre avec la même idée
c'est débile ou quoi
tu prends c'est toujours pareil aussi
aujourd'hui je suis assez
créatif aujourd'hui je sais pas ce qui
m'arrive
mais après bon ça change un peu les
ennuis quand même mais j'empêche forcer
6 empêche cavaluer 6
c'est assez malin après j'ai plus de 4
c'est le problème il y a un
embouteillage sur la case D4 je peux pas
je peux pas tout faire
d'ailleurs oui je viens de voir sur le
chat antimes qui nous qui nous dit qu'il
y ait des quatre qui l'avait pas vu ton
petit message et ben ça a l'air pas mal
que des quatre en rien
alors pas mal
après qu'il était trop aussi pas mal
aussi
ou pas
il y a pas de 4
et je me lasse quand même de tout manger
et bon c'est quand même plus dur sur
Cavalo 6 si je mange tout
et on arrive un petit peu s'en sortir ça
a l'air OK quand même pour les noirs
je pense qu'il faut agir maintenant il
faut agir dessus et qu'elle est quatre
dans votre bien
et des quatre comment tu défends en fait
malheureusement on n'est pas on n'est
pas
en live avec les caméras ou celle qu'on
a une minute de retard mais j'aime bien
des fois voir les caméras pour voir pour
voir la réaction des joueurs face à des
coûts comme cavalle des quatre par
exemple tu passes avec des 4 et voir la
tête de Magnus pour voir si le début ou
pas mais comme on a du retard et ben
on peut pas le faire on peut pas le
savoir
donc il y a des quatre sur cavalier E4
dans le chat
peut-être que j'ai ici
cavalier F5 au pire des cas je suis
Détroit peut-être aussi non mais ça m'a
l'air durant il y a beaucoup trop de
possibilités
ça m'a l'air trop à du vessie là
alors qui me trouve la tactique sur le
chat
qui me trouve le gain des blancs
[Musique]
vous voyez un
je prends le défenseur du cavalier aussi
puis je le mange
bien sûr il jouera pas ça mais le fait
de 5 ça empêche du coup
la défense de Magnus donc là il arrive
pas à roquer Magnus il arrive pas du
tout à
il n'arrive pas du tout à
l'heure je suis pas sûr qu'il est raté
peut-être qu'il l'a pas vu oui peut-être
qu'il l'a vu et qui pensait que
cavaluation était alors était plus fort
encore donc voilà les joueurs ils voient
tactiquement il voit tellement tout en
fait
on sait même pas s'il l'a vu qu'il a mis
de côté ou qu'il l'a pas vu alors tout
le gars 5 c'est quand même pas mal aussi
après j'avoue qu'il y avait des quatre
étais pas mal aussi j'avais bien qu'elle
avait des quatre mais cinq ça propose
aussi des quatre qui est aussi
intéressant et la caveille ça a été
jouée pas mal Musse et je pense que je
peux toujours continuer à jouer mes
coups
on sait pas si c'est mieux qu'avec des
quatre
choses mais il y a pas des quatre alors
que là avec cavalier 5
avec cavalu E5 et ben j'ai toujours des
4 qui est possible donc en fait c'est un
coup qui me permet de continuer mon idée
tout en continuant avec des gares en
vrai
c'est je pense et kif les deux coups se
valent et eux
et la caverne F7 il faut voir mais je
risque
prise je me décloue je vais pas revenir
en 8 je suis pas débile
et là maintenant je manque de pièces je
crois
qu'un cavalier en G5 ce serait pas la
même mais là je manque de pièces
malheureusement Babou
donc la gavage
comment ce qu'on fait est-ce que je
continue la Capelle C3 parce que je joue
des quatre
ce que je mange en justice
c'est chaud en tout cas
six minutes pour
pour aller raisin contre 5
[Musique]
qui est hyper logique alors petit rock
n'est pas possible encore une fois parce
que j'ai cavalé l'écran puis on prend et
d'un point de 7 c'est la même en fait
c'est la même donc il peut pas manquer
sur dessin
je dois avoir un Cabal étranger 6 je
pense des fois j'avais cherché
du tout il y a des seins
je j'accepte
[Musique]
là
j'ai plus de menaces
cavaler prend suivi de fou prend S5 avec
le clouage qui va faire très très mal à
malus croit et fuite forcer faut
s'enlever du clouage un jour pour
pouvoir bouger le fou parce que cette
loi j'ai il devient infernal
pas bien là il est pas bien c'est
maintenant qu'il faut le qu'il faut le
secouer un petit peu
on cherche un peu les tactiques moi je
trouve pas
je trouve rien
les trucs dans tous les sens mais ça
marche jamais
ah ouais mais les amis c'est pas fort en
fait quand tu connais pierre Barbot
tu sais que les amis sont juste nulles
en fait complètement nuls et donc je dis
ça parce que il est connu sur les
réseaux etc et pour ceux qui le
connaissent franchement
une fois que tu le connais tu te rends
compte que Amy c'est plus que c'était
avant
du coup ouais non
la F3 avec la jouer
mais bon il sait que c'est comme ça
cette bonne guerre
tu le sais
ça a été joué si je mange là regardez de
la ressources qu'ils ont c'est genre
très très vite cavalier champion HD en
prise donc j'ai pas le temps de manger
B7
comment est-ce que je joue là j'ai pas
envie de toi malin peut-être c'est de
manger le pion c'est 5 mais il y aura B6
peut-être un B7 j'arrive un peu à
attaquer ses pions
ça a l'air pas mal quand même pour les
blancs encore une fois mais
[Musique]
avoir j'ai pas envie
je vais l'enlever là
c'est leur métier ah oui non mais les
joueurs sont sont extrêmement forts bien
sûr c'est une blague
Olympe c'est une blague par rapport à
par rapport à mon ami Pierre Barbeau qui
en ce chamaille sans arrêt c'est un ami
qui est assez fort en fait mais bon
j'aime bien lui dire qu'il est nul parce
que
c'est comme ça entre nous on se dit
plein de choses sympas
mais
oui non c'est un très bon joueur
taquinage
donc donc là du coup tu as B7 enfin
voilà plutôt plutôt sympa
parce que à Becker ouh là là c'est
vraiment le coup
très intéressant il ouvre toute la
position il garde en plus les
découvertes par contre c'est quand même
cloué il s'est cloué tout seul mais
quelqu'un est découverte à voir
Raoul toujours
la banane
qui se passe quoi
question bête
parce que c'est pour jouer qu'elle va
laisser deux
encore une fois je pense qu'elle va elle
va me répondre bientôt
mais j'ai pas trouvé alors il y a eu des
coups hein
moins bête c'est quoi là
ok j'ai pas vu c'est défendu ok donc
bouger le cavalier quelque part
ok
ok prise moi j'ai 8 dames et 7
et
maintenant bah les pions sont quand même
assez faibles ici
j'aime beaucoup quand même la pollution
la position blanche même si la jauge
voyait qu'elle est encore là en pratique
c'est tellement difficile le roi et la
moitié en réseau de map du couloir tous
les pions sont faibles les pièces sont
quand même loin la tour la tourage fuite
on parle même pas
quand même ultra dur pour pour Magnus
après ma glue tous les cours franchement
tous les coups à chaque fois c'est un
petit peu
c'est un tube blason de voir que trouve
tous les coups tout le temps c'est mais
bon
quelle durée
Magnus ouais après je pense que il a pas
enfin il a je descends pas forcément le
mieux mais je pense que
il tombe des choses quoi
à 6
ça pourrait être intéressant de faire
exprès de perdre racises pour
mal placer la dame et partir après qu'un
cavalier G4 peut-être un truc comme ça
qui pourrait être intéressant de voir
H5 a été joué ok il veut sortir la tour
clairement
ce calcul beaucoup beaucoup
[Musique]
bien plus que que ce qu'on pense et en
plus là savoir qu'ils sont ils sont
remplis de ça enfin ils sont embêtés ils
font du rapides et je pense que c'est
marrant parce qu'en fait on arrive au
15e coup il avait plus que cinq minutes
à la pendule chacun au bout de 15 coups
et en fait je pense que si on leur
demande de tous ces sont calculés en
calculer
un nombre de variantes
monstrueuses auxquelles nous on a même
pas pensé ils ont ils sont extrêmement
extrêmement forts
[Musique]
propose enfin quand il joue la jauge
elle bouge pas quand moi je joue la
chose
on s'aime bien on s'aime bien avec la
jauge on s'aime bien c'est une belle
histoire d'amour donc H3 était joué
pourrait empêcher H3 quand même ce
serait que ça fait c'est embêtant H3
c'est une scène avec un B3
au troisième coup le 4 c'est 5 Cavalaire
F3 E63
en H3 était voué attention Magnus mal au
temps Damas 3 pour revenir peut-être
madame B5 aussi pour venir un peu par
là-bas
et moi comme un col avance mais je sais
pas ça dépend des positions des
pollutions qui sont très très forcées ou
tu peux voir plus de coupes que d'autres
donc c'est vraiment des positions
des positions mais bon clairement
clairement bien moins loin que Magnus
vraiment je suis même pas un dixième de
ce qu'il voit les joueurs c'est des
c'est des machines c'est juste
ouf salut ma Grey salut Mika j'ai sauté
la ligne
donc cavalier F4
pour venir madame parla même
menace un jour
une minute 25 chacun là c'est les
lunettes merci
c'est vrai que ça me pose des problèmes
peut-être que du coup dans
mon idée qui est un peu un peu gênant
même si j'encabre encore encore tout au
sein de derrière c'est pas que là
c'est débile je pense pas rien à débile
peut-être que ça j'ai ça
je vais l'enlever
je vais essayer de changer les dates
donc à faire mais il y a eu des cinq
je pense c'est pas un mauvais coup faut
être ça a l'air pas mal
ah oui Non Stop fiche même pas alors
tout ici tourne là peut-être
mais je pense que le noir sont assez
content quand même d'échanger cette tour
qui qui faisait rien
j'ai pas trop le choix ou est-ce que
j'ai le choix parce que ça sent qui met
l'impression que ma tour s'active
au final ma tour de quoi devient hyper
forte quoi je pense qu'on peut avoir 5
sur ça je dois faire tout ça je pense
[Musique]
je pense qu'on est obligé de faire
taureau 500 tour H5
là ça fait peur quand même hein
on va manger là-haut ou alors peut-être
faire tour au sein et tout
aussi est une idée pour garder le
contrôle de la colonne
et essayer de ramener une pièce à
l'attaque donc elle est prise
qu'elle va les prendre force
être jolie sauf que je mange là mais
voyez ça ça cache le matin c'est un coup
joli qu'on fera un Bullet mais qui ne
marche pas
pour
pour prendre la colonne ouverte donc
tout recettes peut être aussi une belle
idée de la part de la
et qui descend en dessous de 20 secondes
là c'est vraiment là
c'est le moment les raisins
il faut revenir au score là
D3 ça me coûte consolide et cavalier
un peu la cavaliers
parce que fou d'être fou des deux c'est
chaud
[Musique]
ça et après
c'est la partie
pourquoi ces blender je ne sais pas
tu as mangé mes deux je prendrai des
cartes je pense je peux faire échec
échec prendre là et prendre la je crois
que c'est perdu pour macbus incroyable
je prends là il prend ici je prends des
quatre ah non je prends pas des quatre
pardon madame B2
il y a pas un truc avec Dame David C5
genre intermédiaire
que la chose qui se qui s'est vachement
vachement esclamé là il y a deux pions
d'avance pour les blancs et je pense à
juste terminer je pense c'est juste
terminé pour Magnus qui va devoir signer
là il y a plus l'échec tout à l'heure le
pion qui avance c'est juste abandon
alors attention c'est 6 va essayer d'un
point F2 quand même et sur C7 il y aura
un perpétuel avec Damien F4 faire
attention quand même dame G3 pour calmer
un peu le jeu de 6 et le pion qui avance
c'est complètement
terminado il garde quand le contact ici
si je boude la dame attention il y aura
ça
le roi qui bouge plus sur voilà il y a
échec Adam
sur roi ici chez échec je pense que
c'est juste un bon nom de Magnus
imminent
[Musique]
faire attention quand même au
perpétuel mais ça devrait quand même
gagner pour pour les blancs
normalement
[Musique]
ça joue encore
et à des raisins qui perdent tout son
avantage selon la jauge
mais c'est un joueur de position 5
secondes chacun
droit G6 il y a plus de temps la pendu
c'est chaud là F4 regarde un point F4
attention il y a plein d'échecs qui
peuvent arriver dans ma chambre
me trois je prends H4
est-ce qu'il va réussir à elle a gagné
dans ma chambre répète un projet de roi
là moi c'est chaud je suis pas sûr qu'il
la gagne et malheureusement
falloir qu'il soit
ouais
en tout cas on les voit encore à la
caméra ça veut dire qu'il joue encore
malgré le décalage 2 minutes qu'on a
avec eux
et Magnus qui a failli tomber continue à
jouer attention à damage de qui est
enfilade
je crois H2O
la dame qui a plus d'un match de et très
joli le petit dommage le petit c'est
celui de cavalier de la part de de
Ali resa qui en fait a une pièce de plus
maintenant au final quoi c'est ouf quoi
alors celui de cavalier je n'aurais pas
du tout pensé c'est monstrueux quoi il
perd le cavalier mais il prend F6
et la finale il y a un plan de plus net
avec en plus le roi qui est mal placé
dans le 6 ou 6 et raté
en plus
c'est quand même archi gagnant pour pour
ça maintenant on va se cacher un peu
c'est je pense là c'est plié ça me
castre à pousser les pions
c'est plié pour Magnus cavalier à deux
points d'exclamation de la part de David
raisin jusqu'au ouf quoi complètement
ouf cette fin de partie ça me Sète dame
C7 il y aurait eu une petite
découverte derrière
c'est terminé en plus elle est résa qui
qui jouent vite pour avoir un peu de
temps en plus vous savez vous avez trois
secondes parcours à chaque fois
complètement ouf c'est une partie
franchement il mérite il mérite les
raisins cette partie
il mérite complètement
il va la gagner celle-là
je pense qu'il essaie de jouer un peu
vite pour récupérer
du temps il y a plus d'échec
plus
et maintenant ben j'ai poussé les pions
en plus il y a échec là
Dame des 6
enfin attention qu'un mot d'échec mais
normalement ça devrait être gagné sans
trop de soucis d'un échec en pouce il
faut pousser là il y a de mes chèques là
mais je reviens ici peut-être
alors pousse le pion je pense qu'il faut
pousser là il faut pousser
il y avait échec et je prenais le pion
ils sont très très malins dans ma
chambre quand même
échec là qui gagne un stand
allez faut cacher le roi
le roi qui va partir par la balle sans
ou attention la jauge qui n'aime pas du
tout ça
là on aime ça au final apparemment roi
des 5 était le coup qui faisait qui
faisait nul direct et bon ils ont plus
de temps la pendule c'est hyper chaud et
en plus ils ont ils ont pas toujours aux
gens si jamais qu'une jauge ce serait
différent s'il savait qu'il y avait des
mauvais coup à chaque fois il pourrait
mieux jouer que ça mais bon c'est un
jouable
allez 7 peut-être
ces trois là peut-être que j'ai l'air de
comment est-ce qu'on termine dans mes
chèques ou dans pas mal aussi la chose
qui n'aime pas ça
même pas ça les joueurs qui font gaffe
sur gaffe
mais c'est hyper compliqué en fait pour
prendre des décisions de la case il faut
juste
calculer 35 coups avant de jouer c'est
horrible 50 coups non 50 coups il a joué
un pion il y a pas longtemps ça va le
faire
alors générale
c'est final d'un pur contre contre dame
peuvent être nulles mais le roi doit
dans un coin pour éviter un peu les
échecs
et échec tout le temps si tu viens alors
là il y a échec contre un chèque sur ça
je leur échec là j'aime cacher je pense
c'est juste perdu alors montre le roi
où est-ce qu'on met le roi c'est encore
un grand question il faut trouver il
faut réussir à sortir à sortir des
échecs
j'aime bien l'âme des quatre
je peux toujours pousser le pied
maintenant si jamais
il y a plus d'échec
120 coups ça fera 50 ah ouais ok
[Musique]
130 coups 130 coups 130 coups là je vois
D6 c'était le 81 donc 80 + +30 et plus
50 par mois ça fait 130
et là ça repart à zéro encore
et une case de la dame et chaque
et là on va réussir à enlever les échecs
ça m'a l'air d'être fini il y a chaque
après voilà je pense c'est contre échec
ok plus d'échec mais toujours ça petit
échelle dame là ça continue
ici
allez comment on termine maintenant des
deux
comment je finis
échec échec d'un truc comme ça ce qui
vient là il y a dameche et dames tu
viens là
[Musique]
OK
mais
voilà j'aurais échec et d'âme
OK
il reçoit avec son roi il se dit que
maintenant que le roi est en G7 il y
aura peut-être plus de possibilités de
pouvoir faire
des contre échecs d'amitié c'est terminé
et je crois que Ali résa a gagné vu
leur body language
il a dû gagner les raisins ce qui est
juste complètement ouf la partie 124
coups pour l'instant
tache il faut bouger le roi voilà il y a
plus de chèque
c'est la même il y a ça encore il va
être le roi ici probablement
voilà échec là voilà et puis déjà
terminé plus de chèque je menace dame et
c'est fini ouais c'est ouf
complètement ouf cette partie attention
en tout cas d'aller Raisa jusqu'au bout
130 coups pour pour réussir à venir à
bout de Magnus alors j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup apprécié le coup ici de by resa
regardez il y a eu dame de menaces
damage 2 enfilade et ici le coup
monstrueux qu'il avait c'est C8
promotion cavalier quoi
parce que
et ben je suis défendu maintenant c'est
joli hein franchement c'est
c'est magnifique magnifique la
proportion cavalier de Dali raisin Dali
Raisa du coup qui va réussir à forcer un
arnaque des dons pour gagner
ce premier match donc là maintenant on
est à deux deux un petit pause je pense
bien mérité pour pour aller raisin qui
va enchaîner très bientôt avec
l'Armageddon donc maintenant je vous
rappelle un peu les règles comment ça se
passe c'est la dernière partie de ce
match donc 645 gagne bon on va voir un
peu les couleurs on sait pas mais le
genre qui passe gagne en gros si
Magnus allait blanc par exemple il a
obligation de gagner OK et avec les
Noirs le jour qu'elle est noire peut
faire nul ou gagner la partie pour se
qualifier
alors la base des
la base des comment dire
des
enchères en fait c'est que
si jamais voilà les deux en fait ils
vont si vous voulez proposer une cadence
avec lesquelles avec laquelle ils sont
d'accord de prendre les Noirs par
exemple moi je dis bah tiens je perds
tout le temps avec les Blancs bah je
vais essayer de prendre les Noirs OK et
du coup les deux joueurs vont proposer
une cadence au hasard 9 minutes 32
contre 10 minutes 45 et le jour qui aura
proposé la cadence la plus petite et ben
va gagner les enchères et pourra choisir
sa couleur par contre il jouera avec
ce temps là du coup c'est un petit peu
chaud
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu chaud
alors je vois passion échec sur le sur
le stream de YouTube alors j'en profite
pour te saluer je crois que je peux que
je te je te connais en ce genre de
quelques mails je t'ai envoyé un mail
tout à l'heure tu m'as pas répondu je
sais pas si tu l'as vu ou pas donc si tu
es bien celui lequel je pense
si tu pouvais voir tes mails et me
répondre c'est assez urgent là voilà
merci à toi en tout cas Alexis pour pour
tes commentaires c'est très sympa
et moi aussi je m'amuse bien avec ces
petits commentaires qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire toujours
un plaisir de suivre ces événements là
et en plus quand on voit des parties
comme comme celles d'Ali resa c'est
juste complètement monstrueux je vais je
vais essayer de voir je vais essayer de
voir sur
[Musique]
sur
slack si j'ai des infos des temps qui
ont été proposés je vais vous dire dès
que je les ai il a pas encore alors moi
je ne suis pas tchadom.fr en fait
c'était ce que je vais faire c'est comme
français quoi mais du coup mon compte à
moi c'est tout ouais moi c'est tout
vous voyez c'est écrit sous mon sous mon
sous mon nom donc j'ai ma chaîne twitch
pour ceux qui veulent venir voir un peu
ce que je fais et toi aussi ma chaîne
youtube stouf échec pour ceux qui
veulent aussi voir ce que je fais en
tant que YouTube j'ai ma partie avec
laquelle je suis passé mettre
international qui va sortir en vidéo à
partir de demain après-midi donc soyez
en tout cas prêt pour pour découvrir
cette partie donc je passais mettre il y
a à peu près un mois donc c'est tout
frais donc les titres de mettre
international donc demain la partie elle
sera elle sera en ligne dans
l'après-midi donc c'est pas encore à
quelle heure en tout cas
voilà voilà
bonjour tu peux nous faire un exemple
concret pour l'histoire de la cadence
que le George choisie imaginons moi je
contre Sébastien
Sébastien il demande à voir 8 minutes à
la pendule et moi je demande à avoir 9
32 et ben toi qui a proposé un temps
inférieur au mien par cette toit qui
gagne l'enfer et toi qui choisis la
couleur que tu veux sachant que si tu as
des blancs tu es obligé de gagner mais
tu as plus de temps que moi et si tu as
les Noirs la nul te convient la nulle te
fait gagner la partie mais tu as moins
de temps que ton adversaire donc c'est
c'est compliqué c'est chaud donc avoir
un petit peu là j'attends un petit peu
[Musique]
ok en fait apparemment je viens de voir
sûrement slack sur mon slack j'ai les
infos et ils ont dit car apparemment
donc la partie va commencer dans de près
5 minutes et les joueurs ne veulent pas
donner le temps ils veulent ils
préfèrent attendre le dernier moment
pour dévoiler les temps donc là moi je
ne sais pas mais justcom international
ne connaît pas les temps donc on va
attendre de voir ce qui se passe et
[Musique]
et on va voir
alors c'est pas 8h c'est 8 minutes elle
a été Martine ah ça y est j'ai le temps
j'ai le temps
Magnus a demandé 8 minutes 8 minutes 56
tandis que
Ali raisin a demandé 9 minutes 10 donc
normalement dans ce qui va se passer
macmus a des noirs
[Musique]
et donc Magnus peut formules c'est
incroyable donc Magnus il va avoir 8
minutes 56 et les Noirs contre 15
minutes pour aller raisin et les bornes
donc elle est résa avec 15 minutes
contre quasiment neuf et ben il a
beaucoup de beaucoup d'avance
beaucoup d'avance autant et en plus il a
les blancs donc c'est le Paris pour
mettre de pouvoir mettre la pression au
temps et sur la position mais en cas de
nul c'est Magnus qui gagne le match donc
les raisins doit absolument gagner la
partie pour gagner le 7 si il y a les
raisins gagnent pas cette partie et bah
le match est terminé ça s'arrête moi je
vous dis au revoir et ça se termine
par contre il y a les raisins cette
partie et bien on va avoir un deuxième
set en quatre parties encore qui va
recommencer ça repart à zéro
donc encore très très chaud donc là on
va voir encore Magnus avec les noirs
on va rester sur cette
cette scène
en vrai moi je moi je veux rester moi je
veux voir à l'Iris à gagner quoi
moi je veux je veux je veux que ça
continue je sais pas vous ce que vous en
pensez mais bon soit on se couche
maintenant et puis bon bah juste enfin
c'est nul quoi
il y a encore tôt et encore 22 ans 23 ça
va
on veut quand même voir du spectacle
allez reste encore
soit une partie
soit au moins quatre
soit encore 6
là il y a encore beaucoup de parties
potentiellement c'est à dire cette
partie on peut être là jusqu'à très tard
par contre c'est les raisins gagne pas
la partie et ben ça va
ça va être la fin
ça va être la fin je vais faire une
pause de 3 minutes je vais aller boire
un petit peu d'eau je reviens d'accord
je vous mets comme je sais que vous
adorez les pubs je vais jouer une petite
pub avant de partir et je vous dis ça à
tout de suite
coucou la pub quel est le meilleur moyen
de suivre n'importe quel événement
échiquier surpris a du monde au tournoi
des candidats en passant par le
speechestre ou les title twist
dayn school tous les plus grands
tournois d'échecs qui se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent aussi
bien sur le site internet que sur nos
applications iOS et Android pour vivre
votre passion comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
rapidement
j'ai trois prises 2 et 4 donc on a
l'impression typique avec le pion isolé
à un moment ça va changer et le poisson
qui va être faible donc Magnus qui
commence avec 8 minutes combien déjà 56
contre 15 minutes là c'est du chaos il y
a pas très longtemps c'est du chaos
c'est 15 + 0 donc là on peut flag et je
pense que les raisins je gênerait pas
pour flag news
désolé Cyril j'ai eu quelques secondes
de retard
donc qui pose
que
donc important pour allumer
l'avantage de temps
[Musique]
parce que quand même sacré à voir autant
et comme c'est du
chaos il faut en profiter quand même
je peux être flagrants
est-ce que vous pensez que votre retour
ça se flag
dans cet événement je pense que oui
en fait les joueurs
qui se connaissent beaucoup qui ont
beaucoup joué ensemble en blettes je
suis sûr de chez sueur car il reste
à 100%
et je pense que les deux joueurs aussi
l'un contre l'autre
je pense que par exemple un caractère
contre un joueur comme un Nantes
peut-être je le ferai pas ce qui est
vraiment un respect plus avec les
joueurs il y a de l'ancienne école mais
contrairement comme un livret A les
joueurs ils savent qu'ils se flattent
tout le temps donc je pense qu'il se
laverait c'est mon avis peut-être mais
je pense qu'il se plairait avec grand
plaisir et c'est les frais bien même
alors Fougères
en fait je pense que les joueurs ça
dépend de quelques jours
parce qu'on a qu'à contre tout le monde
s'en fout pas de respect par contre
karassen il flagray ça dépendrait comme
qui ils ont je pense
flag ça veut dire gagner autant en fait
crabes alors attention voilà jauge là
qu'il n'aime pas du tout le coup d'aller
raisin
pourquoi donc
tout re 8 ouais ça a l'air d'être pas
mal sur le cavalier là
peut-être autre chose que que cavalier
de cavalier le 2 est-ce que Dame des
trois était un coup ou F3 peut-être mais
bon F3 et comme des idées sur le
diagonale là c'est un peu peur tu vois
là
et maintenant on fait quoi F3
il y a des seins qui peut arriver
attention à vos amis attention à ça
[Musique]
sur B5 du coup
ça a l'air de tenir peut-être des quatre
c'est très très compliqué ces lignes
il y a tout en l'air juste pour voir les
quatre c'est gagnant
ou pas sur cavalier
je pense que j'ai un problème sur le
cavalier 2 genre sur ça qu'elle va les
prendre il faut prendre
j'ai fout et à la fin je te reprends en
deux
c'est il y a tout en l'air en fait
qu'une brochette qu'on a la colonne E
donc
encore une fois j'ai peur de perdre il y
a toujours ce thème qui vient obstruer
un petit peu du Fou
peut-être pas beau mais un carré
avoir
ta bague qui a une belle pause il a
réfléchit que 2 minutes et il a une
belle position avec les Noirs je vous
rappelle que les raisins est obligé de
gagner cette partie pour forcer le
dernier set de l'événement c'est à
lireza ne gagne pas cette partie c'est
terminé je vais me coucher
sur 15 mois avec aucune caisse défendue
j'ai peur pour C8 sur toutes les pièces
blanches
s'il y a trop d'un
donc il faut gagner que les gens
il faut gagner quoi alors x 3
McFly
tout se passe bien ton micro j'ai pas eu
du tout
de problème dites moi sur le chat si
vous entendez bien s'il y a un problème
et ben dites le moi je peux essayer de
régler mais il me semble que le micro il
est plutôt plutôt bien
à tout le monde dit que c'est parfait de
son côté merci beaucoup à prendre les
échecs
le micro est très bon peut-être que le
problème vient de chez toi McFly donc la
catastrophe peut-être de ton PC
donc je suis désolé moi aussi
donc avec les jouets
et c'est quand même très très embêtant
pour les blancs quand j'ai du mal à vous
de prendre là-dessus comme la team
là-dessus c'est vraiment une position
difficile
d'empêcher des quatre
défendre le cavalier
de bouger un peu comme ça
ce qui a une tactique ou un truc pas si
mal
mais bon
à moins que j'ai une tactique que je
viens de voir entre avec ces deux et B4
avoir
compliqué
qu'est-ce qu'on joue avec les Blancs
[Musique]
merci beaucoup à
merci à toi
je crois
on pose doucement sur classcom débutant
j'ai actuellement mon meilleur hello 118
[Musique]
et ben le meilleur conseil que je peux
te donner pour l'instant à ton niveau de
faire énormément de de tactiques c'est
le c'est le plus important à ton niveau
la tactique c'est c'est extrêmement
important bien plus que les ouvertures à
votre niveau il y a beaucoup de gens qui
pensent que les ouvertures c'est c'est
le mieux mais en fait ça sert à rien
parce que vous allez jouer contre des
joueurs qui vont pas du tout connaître
ce que vous jouez et ça ne sert à rien
par contre ça ne sert à rien à votre
niveau vous devez apprendre à calculer
et c'est et c'est le plus important pour
toi donc vraiment fait des exercices
fait du calcul fait des tactiques c'est
le numéro 1
pour t'aider à progresser à ce niveau là
donc tu cliques et aussi analyse de tes
parties c'est aussi c'est aussi
intéressant et oui je vois je vois les
les commentaires sur YouTube
tout ce qu'il faut pas faire en fait
c'est
ça va pas du tout à votre niveau les
ouvertures ça sert à rien
alors comment je m'en sors ici je peux
je fous des cartes quand même d'amener
des deux peut-être sortir
sortir de ce couloir
c'est hyper dur encore j'aime pas du
tout la pollution
[Musique]
au centre c'est vraiment des cousues
comme position
mal barré pour le pour le gain bah ouais
ouais c'est une position qui est un peu
difficile
[Musique]
voir si on peut jouer à un truc du style
fou B4
[Musique]
dans tous les cas c'est pas simple du
tout pour
pour les raisins qui est toujours mieux
autant c'est la seule bonne nouvelle
pour un
[Musique]
deux points et demi non là c'était la
dernière partie du du
[Musique]
mat c'est normal
c'est Magnus qui l'emporte
donc absolument que Magnus perte parti
donc tous avec la livraison donc je
décale peut-être
dans ma 5 tours
torcer un tout liquide et manger à deux
du mal à calculer je suis fatigué aussi
un peu moins toute la semaine je
commence à tiens à peindre n'importe
quoi c'est de manger à deux dents dans
lequel dans quel ordre et 3 plutôt parce
que
c'est un petit peu ce que j'avais dit à
l'envers
il a raison il faut garder les pièces
parce que il doit gagner avec les Blancs
donc l'année il faut qu'il ait des
pièces mais bon il y a des idées
intéressantes la base de Tour Eiffel
rouge vous pouvez faire un four à
c'est dur pour les blancs de vraiment
créer un truc
là
c'est clairement logique mais ça montre
bien ça je crois que j'ai joué que la
pollution elle est quand même pas très
bonne vous voyez
il manque des choses donc dans mes trois
ici je vais
qui sont ils sont on va dire importantes
l'idée de commencer avec
avec
une position tranquille pour pouvoir
jouer des chèques mais tu apprends 35
coups sur la nageoire alors tu as mis
les lots c'est complètement
tu trompes quoi c'est pas là qu'il faut
travailler quoi
sortir du clouage 4 sur 3
qui est très déplaisant
ça me forcerait à partir et laisser mon
four en privé ouais ça va être très très
dur pour Magnus là ils ont même temps
ils ont un peu plus
je pense que malgré peut-être encore
plus fort cette partie mais cela il a
échangé les dames ce qui lui donne cette
position et en fait
quasiment la position allait quasiment
impardable pour les noirs
et Magnus joue pour la nul je vous
rappelle en cas de nul Magnus gagne
l'événement donc il a bien fait et vous
très solide il prend pas de risque il y
aurait peut-être pu faire plus mal mais
ce qu'il a fait c'est juste parfait pour
la situation de la du match en pas de
risque il essaye pas de de gagner avec
KO
parce que
on l'a vu si on reprend je perd le flou
et on pourra bouge pas le coup bouge pas
la Safa pour C3 mais ouais mais bon
ça va être je pense que c'est un
cauchemar pour ça parce que gagner ça
c'est impossible donc là il demande il
menace et l'élimination de défenseur il
mange de cavalier pour manger le fou en
dessert
et là je me souviens pas en plus
savent comment ça à sentir un peu le
sapin cette histoire
on pourra lire ça faire nul ou perdre
c'est exactement pareil c'est pour ça
qu'il prend c'est pour ça qu'il prend
qui prend des risques
pas trop
comment il gagne pas ça
tu peux faire un truc ou pas mal une
pièce même si c'est pas mal aussi viser
un peu tout ça
trop de problèmes il faut 5 mois
merci au revoir
[Musique]
je vous rappelle
c'est quand même pour être sûr que il
puisse pas gagner
et maintenant comment est-ce qu'on joue
tout à l'heure
pour essayer de
bloquer un peu j'ai cinq cavaliers
je sais pas
c'est maintenant avec tout ce qu'on a
c'est vrai que
j'ai joué
match 2 et demi mais c'est l'Armageddon
en fait une carte
quand on arrive avec en Armageddon et
ben les noirs doivent les noirs peuvent
faire mieux et
tu as mal à un petit coup cavalu étroit
de Magnus
sortant
en plus ça va être
ça va être terminé d'ailleurs on a
Terrac en notre chat YouTube qu'il avait
tout vu qui est anticipé
il y a une minute de décalage mais ouais
mais malheureusement c'est les citer un
peu enquitrish et ça ben n'y est pour
rien enfin c'est comme ça mais c'est
quand même cool qu'on a les caméras
mais bon
vu comment ça se passe là ben c'est fini
car ça a gagné pour moi parce que là il
faut gagner que pour pour avoir encore
un set gagner ça avec les Blancs contre
Magnus c'est impossible et le pire du
pire c'est qu'elle dinosa et moi bien
longtemps donc même comme ça vous voyez
bien que
donc voilà quoi
c'est fini
ça va être nul ma petite partie elle est
limite gamme pour les noirs
[Musique]
et pour gagner pendant le sport que s'il
peut faire mieux maintenant il va
prendre la nuit parce que
la nulle fait gagner le match donc il va
pas prendre le risque ils veulent
essayer de
ne pas perdre pour être gagné tout
simplement par contre si tu as eu les
blancs la MINUS je vous garantis qu'il
aurait pas du tout pareil
si Magnus avait
[Musique]
si Magnus avait eu les blancs il rejoint
différemment bien sûr il y aurait pas
essayé falloir parler
direct il aurait plus tôt essayer de
gagner mais bien sûr par rapport par
rapport à la situation et ben on fait ce
qui est plus simple
nul et maintenant je me lance
il faut prendre
complètement impardable
pour
pour aller raisin enfin pour ma news
qui pourrait se
dessiner comme ça mais
sur Magnus c'est pas un peintre
il va pas se prendre ce matelas
et ça va être perdu très vite
là on peut quasiment tout faire avec les
noirs
même prises
[Musique]
sont bons je pense pour la mort
il y a pas d'erreur possible
déconnexion
c'est la seule chose qui pourrait
arriver parce que l'air politique de
Game Magnus et good
il y a vraiment aucune chance pour
arriver
à l'échec
je sais pas est-ce que tu connais un
peintre qui faisait chacun
bonjour
[Musique]
les Noirs vont
aller à dames en fait c'est fini ça va
être perdu
en fait pour les raisins
ça va être perdu en fait pour
[Musique]
pour relier les uns et ouais on a vu les
caméras on a vu les joueurs
la manger ici l'important sinon il y a
peut-être de petits coups F5 qui pouvait
mettre le réseau de maths j'avais
proposé
prise 5
et chaque encore une fois
juste ne pas perdre la partie
[Musique]
du monde c'était en 2013 première année
où il est juste pour du monde il a battu
à Nanda
aussi il prend il y a un joli F2
[Musique]
allez plus de temps la pendule pour les
raisins sur la partie et
perdue abandon et gain de Marius
cartelé
une très belle résistance il a fait un
super match contre
la partie d'avant était juste
monstrueuse et je pense qu'il a tout
donné lors de la dernière partie
et cette partie là était pas très très
bonne mais c'est dur de faire enfin de
revenir
[Musique]
une partie après la grosse partie qu'il
a fait juste avant la fin de pleine lune
mais il s'en fout de la nuit en fait
parce que je pour gagner donc si il fait
nul
s'il fait nuit juste hyper quoi nul ou
perdre c'est pareil donc il a tout tenté
jusqu'à la fin il a bien fait
voilà alors pour les petites choses
rapidement je vais vous montrer un peu
le bracket vous voyez le paquet des
filles
avec trois deux Mabus invaincu un vaincu
dans ces torse au tournoi il a tout
gagné et c'est vraiment bon maintenant
il est quand même été extrêmement
extrêmement fort
et impressionnant moi j'ai voulu malin
et aussi contre fearuja
en
espagnol c'était vraiment impressionnant
et encore ici c'est impressionnant
rapidement pour demain alors demain
commence le speechestre donc c'est un
tournoi avec bon vous verrez demain ça
paraît 15 heures sur ce qu'on va faire
donc
trois heures que on a qu'à nous il y
aura 15 scène il y aura des petits
indiens il y aura plein de monde donc
1h30 de 5 + 3 une heure de trois plus
deux et une demi-heure de une plus une
ça commence demain et ça va durer ça va
durer plusieurs petites semaines voilà
voilà donc merci encore à tous d'avoir
suivi ce stream c'était hyper cool de
passer ça en votre compagnie donc moi je
vous dis pour ma part à très bientôt on
se parle bientôt
et puis écoutez ben bonne nuit à vous
bonne semaine demain c'est lundi il faut
se lever il faut travailler ou à l'école
pour certains qui reprennent aussi des
cours donc je vous dis bonne soirée à
tous passez une bonne nuit et à très
bientôt ciao ciao